the governor of oklahoma has officially
signed into law a bill banning the
performing of abortions except in any
circumstance to save the mother's life
and i mean this is the boldest move
we've seen in the pro-choice pro-life
political arena in the past year there's
been a lot of states that have been
enacting restrictions on after how many
weeks can you get an abortion oklahoma
just went for it and it is widely
speculated that in the next two months
we could see the supreme court overturn
roe v wade it's looking more and more
like that may be the case
even many left-wing activists agree they
think this is very it's going to be
apocalyptic apocalyptic so we'll get
into all of that stuff plus we've got a
bunch of stories about these parental
rights and educations uh parental rights
and education bills we saw this in
florida many other states are seeking to
enact bills that are similar but now
we're seeing that maryland and new
jersey are kind of going the opposite
direction maryland actually has a
mandate that's going to require gender
ideology being taught with some uh let's
just say explicit i'll put it this way
if i were to tell you what they were
what they were teaching these kids
youtube would probably demonetize this
stream so we'll we'll don't worry we'll
explain it but i think you get the idea
through innuendo plus we got we got a
bunch of stuff to talk about in terms of
crime new york obviously there was a
very serious tragic incident we'll talk
about that and oberlin college lost a
major lawsuit after accusing a small
bakery of being racist and they're
refusing to pay those uh those fees
those uh the settlement so we'll get
into all of that joining us today is a
huge group of people but uh we'll go
through all of them we got matt walsh
thanks for hanging out man yeah great to
be here excited about it do you want to
introduce yourself uh well you said to
be quick so i thought that was it you
know oh you can get a little bit more
than that well i'm excited to be here
i'm and uh honored to be
you know lgbt author and now a women's
studies scholar as well is what i'm
adding to my to my resume so great to be
here right on we got elijah schaefer
yeah uh i'm the host of slightly
offensive podcast on youtube you can
check it out co-host of you are here and
i gotta say man it looks like uh the
youtube money is good because that a
star trek portal that beamed me in here
from dallas i haven't seen one of those
it's your newest toy very nice it's it's
a satellite and it beams you and then
bounces you off the satellite to
nashville yeah and it was really fun and
i only lost a finger but it's not you
but it's not you the original you is
dead and this is a copy with all your
memories the key thing is i've been dead
inside for 28 years so we're doing all
right
we got libby hey everybody libby evans
editor-in-chief of the post-millennial
glad to be here in nashville
and eventually i will figure out where
everyone is these new cameras are really
thrown away
this time it's exciting but i'm also
here i'm pushing buttons unsuccessfully
i thought you were just going to skip
sheamus yeah just like oh i'll try this
one i know another white guy with a
beard yeah i know another one of them
i'm sheamus
am i here now am i am i on screen is it
my time to shine i'm seamus coughlin i
am the creator of freedom tunes we do
animated political cartoons we just
released one today on joe biden i think
you guys will love it we're releasing
one on thursday about groomer teachers
so go over there subscribe check it out
and we're going to be talking about
grimmer teachers but before we do my
friends head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com to pick up your
biotrusts keto elevate c8mct oil powder
normally i have the bag to hold up but
we're here in nashville i don't have the
bag uh i've been doing keto for some
time and you may have noticed that i
kind of lost a bit of weight since uh
the end of last year because i've been
cutting out the sugar i've been putting
the kilo keto elevate stuff in in my
coffee and i think it's done me wonders
so again go to eatrightandfeelwell.com
you'll get 51 off you'll also get a
60-day money-back guarantee keto elevate
provides your body only c8 the most
ketogenic mct that means it provides
support for energy levels healthy
appetite management mental clarity and
focus athletic performance seriously
i've been i've been feeling great
five grams of the highly sought after
mct eight per scoop keto elevate
personally it's my favorite mct you get
free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help biotrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
you will also get free vip live health
and fitness coaching from biotrust's
team of expert nutrition and health
coaches for life with every order and
their free e-report the top 14 ketogenic
foods with every order over at
eatrightandfeelwell.com biotrust we love
you thank you for sponsoring the show
and don't forget head over to
timcast.com become a member we're going
to have that extra spicy members only
show coming up around 11 p.m eastern for
everybody so sign up become a member if
you want to watch that as a member
you're helping keep our journalists
gainfully employed they all love you so
much and we all do and don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the url to this video
wherever you can right now if you're on
youtube watching live just click it post
it wherever you can we uh we are
eternally grateful for your grassroots
marketing support
let's jump into this first story from
timcast.com oklahoma oklahoma governor
signs bill making performing an abortion
a felony the law grants an exception for
abortions performed to save the life of
the mother
governor kevin stitt signed senate bill
612 on april 12th the measure makes it a
felony to perform an abortion except to
save the life of a mother anyone who
performs an abortion could face up to 10
years in prison and a 100 000 fine the
law goes into effect in 90 days quote
we want to outlaw abortion in the state
of oklahoma said during a signing
ceremony i promised oklahomans that i
would sign every pro-life bill that hits
my desk and that's what we're doing here
today women who seek or receive an
abortion are not subject to criminal
charges under the bill now my question
is
roe v wade still exists right so what's
going on
well i mean
first of all i'm never satisfied so
the bit there about except to save the
life of the mother i'm a little
i want to read more into that because i
i don't think that exception should be
there because
usually when you look into that you find
that well
saving the life of the mother what
they're really talking about is uh if
the mother is in emotional distress then
she can still get the abortion so you
have to look into that because in
reality in reality there there is never
a need for an abortion to save a
mother's life it never actually happens
but putting that aside um i think what
we see here is the republican party and
this is like a shock for those of us who
grew up we're so used to republicans
being milk toast and
and uh cowardly and many of them still
are but we're starting to see in some of
these states oklahoma florida like the
republicans are actually going on
offense which is exactly what you have
to do is is go on offense and try to try
to enact laws according to your own
value system rather than always playing
defense and if you believe that abortion
is the murder of a child
then of course you're going to do
everything within your power to outlaw
you're not going to sit around and say
well supreme court has spoken
it's the murder of a child i think i
think there's some uh i think there's a
semantic issue here as well so you said
there's there's never a you said there's
never a circumstance to having a
performance abortion to save the life of
the mother yeah
so do you want to just elaborate on that
well
usually you hear about this uh abortion
to save the life of the mother thing and
these these especially late term
abortions
and um so what i guess you got to use an
example so like one example would be
um let's say the mother
is is pregnant and then has some sort of
medical complication um
cancer or something like that and and
you have to end the pregnancy
especially later in in um
later term
well yeah you end the pregnancy to save
the mother's life you don't have to kill
the child first though you can deliver
the child at least try so you could yeah
you can at least attempt it so
we we i i could submit and agree
that there are times when to save the
mother's life you have to end the
pregnancy
especially in later terms
um but you don't have to killing the
child is an extra step that is not
necessary you can deliver the child and
in many of these life-saving
quote-unquote life-saving abortions you
have children that could be delivered
and you set them up to the nicu and
there's there's a good chance that the
child could still survive yes there's
children that survive at like 21 weeks
at this point exactly yeah so viability
continues to get lower and lower so so
just just to clarify uh excite i
mentioned a semantic issue is uh what
you're saying is they should at least
try to save the life of the child if
they're because abortion here's what
abortion is abortion is the direct
intentional killing of the child there
is never a time when you need to commit
the direct intentional killing of the
child to save the mother so if there's
if late term abortion doesn't make any
sense you know third trimester abortion
is completely nonsensical because the
child can survive right exactly because
in the late term abortion you're still
delivering the child there's still a
delivery that happens
but you kill the child first why do you
need to kill the child so just deliver
the child just to further clarify it
in in the instance where there is a
severe abnormality and the baby likely
will not survive and the mother likely
will not survive a birth you're saying
that if they were to
deliver the baby or maybe a c-section
they can at least try to save both is
that what you're saying
absolutely there's there's no reason why
you wouldn't try to do that unless
you're just saying that well the child's
life doesn't count he has no moral worth
which is what our laws say right now in
most states is that the child's life he
has no moral worth we don't have to try
to save him it's an interesting point
yeah and i want to mention this because
i basically said something along those
lines on the last episode where we did
discuss this there are procedures that
will be referred to as abortions in
order to make the argument that abortion
is ever medically necessitated and it's
just not true so
if there is an operation that is
required to save the life of the mother
but that poses a risk to the life of the
unborn child that is not the same thing
as an abortion uh and there's a
principle known as the principle of
double effect where you're trying to do
one thing and there might be a negative
unintended consequence but it's not the
same thing morally as intending to do
the secondary thing which can result
yeah that's what i was getting to is
that that's a good point because the
cancer example is one where maybe the
mother is diagnosed with late stage
cancer and you have to you know chemo or
something and
and there's a chance that that will kill
the child well if you're not directly
and intentionally killing a child you're
just you're doing a a procedure to try
to save the mother's life and tragically
the child dies in the process yeah that
is not an abortion well that's the same
thing too when it comes to to the
medical procedure because we're talking
about euthanasia specifically ending uh
you know long-term care or making people
comfortable as they die i mean there's a
big difference of intentionally you know
injecting a lethal dose of an opiate to
end somebody's life or some sort of a
solution that would kill them versus if
somebody's already on you know hospice
and they already are their organs are
running at 20 30 40 capacity and then
you give them some sort of an opiate and
their heart just simply cannot process
cannot take it their liver cannot
process the drug so then they go into
organ failure and die are you then gonna
say that the hospice nurse you know
murdered the woman did she go in to kill
her is that is did she euthanize her no
you'd go well she did what she could to
make her comfortable and that then she
died and responded differently and so
what we always do is we put a lot of
things in umbrellas it's like the lgbtq
community they keep adding letters to
decide what's involved in our group
abortion has an expansive definition
where sometimes you've even heard of
steel births counted as abortion if they
force you know if they force the the the
delivery and it's a stillbirth they go
oh it was an abortion because the baby
was dead and you go that's not an
abortion that baby was dead so they
forced the delivery but it allows them
to it allows them to umbrella to justify
the means and that's a constant issue
that i see and i want to make one little
point here like you were saying earlier
the problem with the the idea of
necessity uh in abortion for for women
to save their lives i mean if you look
at what's happening in canada right now
with with the euthanizing uh argument
they want to be able to euthanize people
who suffer with depression with
schizophrenia with anxiety they're
pushing something they already do in
northern europe and it's really
devastating
usually they actually put a young woman
to death
so you were depressed a few years ago
and it's really yeah she wanted to be
euthanized um kill your baby i'm
depressed i don't want to have a baby so
where do you where do you draw the line
of what's what's uh putting the mother's
life in jeopardy i think matt you got
some nuance that is often uh left out of
the conversation too because you know my
my line of questioning was certainly
there's going to be some circumstance
where the mother and the baby's life are
both in jeopardy
but the term abortion i think is often
just meant to imply
taking the baby out afterwards it's sort
of uh there's no there's no real thought
to it so when you explain that well now
i understand if there's a circumstance
and correct me if i'm wrong in which the
mother and the baby might both likely
die
well if they have to remove the baby
they can try and save it right and and
our in our this is it's really a miracle
the way that our technology has
progressed that now you can deliver a
baby at 21 weeks and and often times the
child will still survive and this is
we're going to get to a point where
eventually we get to the point with
technology where a child can survive
outside of the womb at any stage
we have a federal rule right we have the
14 day rule for research
um where you can
where scientists researchers can
uh basically take um
you know a fertilized embryo and grow it
in a lab and you can grow it up to 14 i
not 14 weeks i have 14 days you can grow
up to 14 days and then you can't grow it
in the lab anymore
um because then you're experimenting on
humans essentially isn't it interesting
how they've decided you're human at
fourteen weeks but before that you're
not 14 days or fourteen days i'm
starting today but before that it's a 14
days so you're not allowed to experiment
after 14 days um so so it counts as life
in a petri dish in 14 days 14 days in
the womb it would knock out that's right
by the law what i'm really interested in
is what i i'm sorry i just gotta ask
let's say we're at 18 weeks pregnancy
and there's a medical complication where
they're like if we don't you know end
this pregnancy the baby and the mother
will die within a week or two i mean i i
know it's an edge case but i'm sure
there are circumstances what would your
perspective be on something like that
well this is where you get into it and
it is important to to emphasize it is
it's like a friend
we're talking about a small percentage
of cases and and the vast majority of
abortions have nothing to do with saving
money but in these kinds of like
incredibly devastating situations then
you have to fall back on these kind of
philosophical distinctions like double
effect um and in a situation like that
then maybe you know you might perform a
life-saving procedure on the mother
that's like almost
certain to result in the death of the
child but that's not your intention it's
not what you're trying to do i see it
right so
that and that's the distinction and
sometimes you get to the real fringe
cases
it does feel like you're splitting hairs
but you're actually not because the
principle's really important
well there are cases where women eschew
radiation treatment for cancer because
they're pregnant and they don't want and
that's and that's heroic but it's like
that's heroic but we would also i'm not
going to sit here and say that if a
mother needs radiation that
that i think
she should be morally required to forego
it that that's a heroic thing and i have
a lot of respect for it i think that you
could still by principal double effect
get the cancer treated agreed right yeah
did you elaborate on double effect
already yeah so so the idea behind the
principle of double effect is if you are
attempting to do something which is good
but there is an outcome that is bad
which can result from it but that bad
outcome is not your intention you're not
morally culpable for it in the way that
you would be if you were just going out
of your way to ensure that outcome but
just to clarify
not as much as you would be there's a
lot of good intentions well i think what
i'm saying not as much as you would be i
want to be really clear here because i
would have to i would have to re-read up
on this principle again i i think it's
actually the case where you're not
culpable yeah this is well this is the
old tram car yes hypothetically you guys
know that but right of course we got to
clarify this because i mean
i i think there are some really dumb
communists certainly there are really
bad ones but who are thinking you know
if i take the farm from the farmer and
give it to the farmhands i'll be doing
great and then everyone starves to death
it's like they're responsible for that
but here's the difference justify the
means exactly that's definitely
different
you mean
they're they're directly doing something
which is intrinsically immoral which is
stealing somebody else's property so
let's get into the icic i see what
you're saying the tram thing it's it's
if i remember correctly it's like a
thought experiment where
there's a train coming down the track
and there's like five people tied to the
track and you're standing next to the
switch and you could pull the switch and
send the train on a different track but
there's one guy on that track at is it
okay to pull the the the uh the lever
and send it off to save the five people
and the answer is
yes because your your intention is to
save the five you're not trying to kill
the one guy um on the other hand though
i disagree yeah i disagree
yeah no no because that's if you're like
i know my action will kill somebody but
i'm going to do it because i think one
that's utilitarianism yes i don't think
so i think i think that's the argument
right it's a utilitarian argument i
think a better argument is just
literally what we're talking about with
a medical procedure a doctor says
this patient has a a tumor next to an
artery if i don't remove it they'll die
in a year but there's a risk they die in
the in the process and they say i'm
gonna i'm gonna intervene if the person
dies we're not going to be like you
murderer we're going to be like yeah and
that you're trying in the train car
situation if somebody pulls that lever
to save the five not at all intending to
kill the one guy are we going to send
that guy to jail for murder i mean i
think clearly we would not that's a good
point too but in man is that scary and
so the difference is like i wouldn't be
that one guy man yeah but the thing is
what if there was no lever to pull and
instead of pulling a lever you just
threw another person in front of the
train to stop it from hitting the other
five now that would be that would be
murder yeah so that's would you agree
that's the problem yeah
if yes i i would i would say so again
i'm not an expert on this but i've also
heard the thought experiment put that
way what if there's just a very rotund
individual who you can push in front of
the trolley they'll stop it i think
that's a different question
as far as i'm aware i think that's a
different situation yeah i i i i don't
think it's a perfect analogy but i do
get what you're saying i think the issue
with the trolley problem is that
there's a guaranteed outcome of five
people dying
or one move which is a binary which is
you know five people dying or the binary
you taking action which kills that one
person
most people when polled say they would
not pull the switch because you are
choosing to kill someone to save five
people i don't i don't know if i agree
with that analogy um simply because i
think you know it's an issue of like an
officer a cop he he
you know he sees someone draw a weapon
and start pointing it at children so he
pulls his gun out and says drop it and
fires the bullet goes through the guy's
shoulder and then hits someone behind
him
severely injuring him we're not gonna
you know we're gonna say in defense of
others this is actually an affirmative
defense in court cases like we have with
cal rittenhouse that you're not
responsible
for what's behind the person when you're
acting in defense of yourself for others
so i think it was specific a specific
circumstance but in the instance where
kyle was attacked they were saying it
was reckless and endangerment because
richie mcginnis was close to him and the
bull could have gone through and hurt
him but ultimately the court decided no
he can't be responsible someone was
threatening his life and he took action
to protect himself
i think that's kind of a better way to
look at it i suppose yeah i mean not to
get too into the weeds with the trolley
problem but i think there's a very good
argument to be made that when you pull
that lever your intention is not to kill
any individual person it's to divert the
train from hitting those five
and it would be morally different if you
actually had a vendetta against that one
person laying on the track and your
intention was to kill them because that
would tell us a about your future
behavior b what your decision-making
process is whether you're dangerous and
see
whether you are actually intending to
kill someone but i disagree because you
know the outcome is guaranteed death
what we're talking about is an outcome
where there's a possibility of it and
it's you're trying to avoid that but
the guys guarantee the death in the in
the trolley problem anyway what i think
is most interesting about the trolley
problem is that uh
the contemplation of it itself is like
the fallacy that we have control over
everything around us you know that we
think that just because there's a
problem that means that we have the
capability of solving it in some
thorough and appropriate way and we
don't i mean you know don't pull the
lever don't kill anybody sometimes bad
things happen
can i just say one thing about the
oklahoma thing which is um governor
stitt doesn't have control over a large
part of his state right native american
reservations have their own
rules and they have their own rules
according to the federal government
so
any native american reservation could
open a casino abortion clinic
and have that combination they could do
the combo they can do whatever they want
and there would be absolutely no ability
for the governor to stop that let me
pull up this story we have this is a
daily mail says sickening youtube star
couple is slammed for comparing abortion
to the holocaust and branding it the
world's most deadly killer in pro
pro-love documentary shared with 13
million followers cole and savannah
lebron have come under fire for
contrasting the amount of people who got
abortions to the amount who were killed
during the holocaust you know the first
thing i'm going to mention is
frame check yeah do do pro-life
conservatives
find this sickening and are they
slamming them or is this the instance of
pro-life personalities large followings
expressing their views and the left
opposing them calling this i think the
daily mail very obviously framed this in
a way that makes it appear like
everybody's mad about this but you know
you guys who are more conservative
pro-life i'm curious what you think
about this couple there's only one
reason to be pro-life and that is that
you believe
that uh well two
the two the two basic
assertions of the pro-life person is
that the child in the womb is a human
being and that it's never okay to
intentionally directly murder an
innocent human being and so if you
believe both of those things then you
you must agree that this holocaust
comparison
is valid because those are we've got 60
million abortions in in the united
states roe v wade are those human beings
are not if they're human beings that's
60 million humans a 60 million people
who are killed and we we've never seen
the systematic slaughter of 60 million
human people before anywhere
on earth so this is a
the 60 million number is this like what
what are the stats what are the stats
behind this
well what's interesting about the what's
interesting about in the u.s abortion in
the u.s is the largest um single group
of women who have abortions are black
women i think it's like 36
of abortions are
for um are done by black mothers and uh
and that doesn't count california i
believe and california has the most
abortions in the country and it doesn't
count california because california
doesn't keep data
on the race of women who whose children
are aborted
so what are we i mean it does seem to me
that there is a genocide against black
babies in this country well my question
is on the statistics about 60 million i
think i think it's important because
the data i saw says that the
overwhelming majority of abortions are
listed as no reason given so i'm
wondering you know of the 60 million
abortions if we're going to say it is
slaughter
are some of these you know how would you
define them is is this entire 60 million
just you know abortion as contraception
are there you know medical crises or
interventions
the vast majority of cases that's that
like we were talking about the medical
we have to get into it again but there's
never actually a reason to to abort a
child for for uh for medical reasons but
this is like we could even put all that
aside because that's like one percent of
the cases 99 of cases are essentially
abortion for contraception it's just you
you don't want the child because you
don't feel like having a kid or because
you don't think you can afford the child
so that is uh i i really you know real
quick because i have i have a
philosophical ethical libertarian uh
question about this that i think i'd
love to hear your thoughts matt and it's
that uh
you know personally
i i have an issue with government
intervention in terms of a person being
required to provide their body to
another person and so the conundrum
arises with two individuals sharing one
body and then the state determining that
one person must provide that body to
another person typically the response i
get and i accept is um well if a woman
chooses to engage in you know
reproductive acts and then she brings
into her harborous life she's accepted a
responsibility in that regard but then
the question of rape arises if a woman
is forced to harbor another person then
the government intervenes and says we're
going to enforce that you will provide
your blood and your body to another
person that kind of freaks me out well
let me i'll respond in general terms
even
because what you're talking about that
principle is true that you shouldn't be
you know forced to provide your body to
another person and that would apply not
just to
babies conceived through rape but to all
babies they're conceived
right so
right here here's the response that's a
challenge um first of all
it turns out we as human beings are not
these autonomous uh free individuals who
have no responsibilities to anybody else
it's just that's just not the reality we
have responsibilities in society but
especially according to relationship so
that's my problem with when it's framed
that way of uh well you shouldn't be
forced to provide your body to somebody
yeah i should be forced to provide like
an organ to my neighbor
but to my child
like the relationship there carries with
it certain responsibilities so what i
would say is
should
let's let's let's take it outside of the
womb
should parents be forced quote unquote
to care for their babies or at least to
find someone else who will like should
it be legal for
a mother to save her six-month-old baby
i don't really want this baby anymore
and to just like throw the child in a
dumpster or drown the child in a in a
bath or even just leave the child at
home and just go somewhere and leave we
would say no you can't do that because
yeah you you don't have a responsibility
to the six month old across the street
but that's your child you're the parent
there is a difference between something
that's directly connected to your
bloodstream and this is why i say i
understand and accept the argument that
if a person chooses to engage in an
action they have a responsibility but if
someone is forced into that position
i just find it creepy that you know a
woman can be victimized by someone then
have i understand the child is innocent
in this regard i absolutely believe that
when it comes to rape but then for just
a person to be told by the state
this the the being that harbor this
harbored in your body that is using your
blood and nutrients
that was put there by force you must
nurture and nourish here's the thing
about that right it's not
the law necessary so we have the laws we
have the state can tell you what you
know tells you what to do or whatever
but the real problem is that we have a
lack of a shared value system and if we
had values that encouraged motherhood
and that encouraged valuing life
regardless of what the law is we would
have less abortion you know and i think
that that's really important we need to
encourage motherhood encourage
parenthood encourage families and if we
did that then it doesn't matter what the
law said people wouldn't kill their
children i thought it was great actually
i don't know if you guys read vogue but
i was checking out vogue and uh
right
and
rihanna is pregnant and her and asap
rocky are having a baby and i thought it
was really cool how she said
this was an unplanned pregnancy we
weren't trying to have kids and
immediately as soon as she got the
pregnancy test back they were like and
now we're on this journey and they went
for it they're not married yet they're
engaged and all of that but i really
thought that it was a very powerful
statement for this extremely popular pop
star to come out and say
i didn't intend to get pregnant and i'm
having my baby and i'm stoked about it i
love that but i i understand that but
you know rape is a specific rape is a
specific thing yeah it's and it's and
it's you can't you can't punish you
can't punish the child for the sins of
your father but you can't if you want if
you want to actually
but the mother is always punished for
the sins of the father that happens all
right
you want to execute somebody for rape
execute the rapist i'm all about that no
but look if so now we're going to hold
out the father and she's going to be
like being the single mother
so so so if you no rehabilitation for
the guy if a person is severely injured
if a person severely injures another
person and that and let's say they're
rushing to the hospital and there's two
people that are injured and they say
this guy's heart's failing hook them up
or this guy's kidneys failing we're
gonna we're gonna connect their
bloodstreams you wake up like hey i
didn't do this to this guy and they say
you can't separate because he'll die and
you're responsible now but i have
nothing to do with this guy there are so
many
differences between abortion and that
that hypothetical it's like a famous
hypothetical judith jarvis thompson
first had that and um
so many differences like one is that
uh unplugging yourself from someone in a
hospital
is different from directly and
intentionally killing a baby
like abortion is not just simply
unplugged it's not you're just like
unplugging you you are killing the baby
you are doing something violent so it
would be more analogous to oh i don't
want to be hooked up to this guy so i'm
going to put a pillow over his face and
kill him and when you start framing it
that way all of a sudden it's it takes
on a different kind of feeling and also
again you're you are disregarding the
relationship so here's the real analogy
what if
your your child
is in the hospital because of something
you did
and um and they need to be hooked up to
you for a short period of time in order
to survive well
i know but would it be acceptable
to because you don't want to be hooked
up to your child to put a pillow over
their face and just kill them of course
not right so so that's
we you can't ignore the relationship and
i don't know why it's it's a problem to
just say just like we say to parents of
born children no matter how the kid was
born we say you are responsible for that
child
you must take care of we are requiring
you by law to take care of the child or
you'll go to jail or find someone else
who will the issue of the issue is the
rape
that's that's the one thing that changes
all of this because i i absolutely say
if a person chooses to engage in these
behaviors they have accepted that
responsibility and they must adhere to
that responsibility but if a woman is
walking through a park on her you know
way home and uh it's you know 5 p.m and
someone grabs her and you know
drags her into a lobby or something or
into an alley and then she rushes to the
hospital and they do a check then a few
weeks later she finds out she's pregnant
and says i never chose this i resisted
they forced it upon me and i do not want
to provide my body to another person
would the state then say we don't care
you have to well yeah and i think this
is this is where the argument gets
stupid in our society you know we see
this amaze sex education for children
and i was reading through some of their
pdfs that was talking about rape
specifically that i thought was
fascinating because he was talking about
the need for consent and there was a
situation that was so outrageous that
would never happen and i noticed
something interesting it goes everyone
was there at a baseball game at philip
and jackson's house and um you know
bethany had drank too much alcohol and i
thought wait a second we're about to
talk about sex and consent we're now
we're starting this underage drinking
okay so there's already the problem here
isn't isn't what i'm trying to say the
problem here isn't the consent the
problem would be the underage drinking
we should work on because that's clearly
what's leading to the behavior when we
talk about the rape though with with
children the key thing is and that's
what i'm saying when we talk about rape
this is why they try to redefine even
what rape is in college where they say a
rape is if you regret it afterwards a
rape
but i'm being serious i'm genuinely
being serious the problem with the rape
argument is that you know you're going
okay if someone was forcibly i'm not
gonna get graphic but there's a violent
crime a violent crime that is heinous
against someone's bot a woman's body and
she's forcibly impregnated well number
one that's not the definition legally of
rape anymore and specifically socially
people just say rape can almost be like
gender it's if you just regretted it
later in life i'm genuinely serious
about it right i don't care about the
left's arguments on this well that's it
legally though i'm saying so
for you not legally for all of you for
your morals and principles i'm just i
have no problem if your answer is the
woman must be forced my my attitude is
that freaks me out i'm not i'm not okay
with it
there's a
to answer your specific question so
uh we can all agree that if a woman is
impregnated through through violent like
forcible rape it's a horrible
unthinkable crime that was committed
against her which is why i think go
ahead and i'm all about executing
rapists um
if they're found guilty
but
you you still you have a person
a person was was created and they exist
now
and so the question is does that person
have moral worth do they have any human
rights at all
or are we going to say that
the manner of your conception determines
whether you have moral worth and human
rights and i'm freaked out by that i i
don't agree with that yeah
real quick just to wrap uh i i i
understand too that
you know
in the instance a woman is raped
she will have the kid she will not die
you know in this circumstance you're
saying kill someone or a woman has a
child for you know is pregnant for nine
months
you know i have a i have a lot of issues
with this scenario as well tim i have a
very similar perspective to yours um in
the event that you're raped
let's say by your father and you're 15
years old um are you then forced to have
that child are you forced to raise that
child you're forced to like you know
look at that child every day and see
that your father i don't agree with you
when you're 15 years old
that exists but that happened that's the
right thing that's the framing and are
you allowed to kill a child ever well i
i don't think that's entirely the
framing i don't care i think there's
activities i think there's i think
there's i think there's more to it than
that right i do think there's more to it
than that i think a big problem with the
abortion conversation is how far it's
it's gone to the point where you have
people you know in
arguing that you should be able to abort
for um
you know
illnesses that you should be able to
abort for deformities that you should be
able to abort for uh you know getting
the biological sex that you want all of
these things like having all of this
extra stuff in this conversation saying
like all of these various reasons that
you could abort your child that you
should be able to you know kill your
baby up to the point of delivery and all
of this
this has made this conversation so
insane
that we completely forget um you know
where it sort of started which was the
idea that it would be safe legal and
rare i'm not in favor of abortion it's
not something that i would do for myself
i don't know what i would do if i was
you know a teen who had been like raped
you know whatever else it is um
and i think that there's i think that it
it makes sense to discuss a woman's life
and what that life is going to be like
after she has been forcibly impregnated
by you know some horrible person i don't
think also the idea that once this woman
has been forcibly impregnated we're
going to kill the man who did it so that
now she can't even get child support
from this guy like he can't do anything
like that's insane too
no i i mean i'm 100 thoroughly opposed
to capital punishment in every single
circumstance i just want to make one
point before you jump in here i think
it's morally insane to say that if
somebody rapes a woman and she becomes
pregnant it's ethically permissible to
murder the child but not to put the
rapist to death
well and isn't isn't it okay i'm not
aware of any reason to be pro-life other
than
the two that i gave that
um the life in the womb is is a human
life
and it is never okay to intentionally
and directly kill innocent human life
that's my whole reason for being
pro-life i don't i can't think of any
other reason and so if that's your
reason for being pro-life then
you you can't make exceptions you can't
say well unless the baby's conceived
through rabies it's more it's
incoherent i think that it makes sense
to talk to this woman this hypothetical
raped person that we're talking about it
makes sense to talk to them and to like
and you know encourage them to have a
child if if they have you know the means
and whatever else and the mental
capability to do that um but i don't
think it i don't think that it should be
the federal government making that
determination there's an interesting
point here is as you know if we try to
create a value system on like moral
points what is what is more
morally weighted
than i think i understand a bit of the
conversation
it's that uh a woman will suffer a
physical constraint and large
inconvenience and
potentially trauma being forced to carry
this child but she'll live and the baby
won't so i understand that point it
there's a challenge in for me in the
idea of
just the extent to which society has
power over other people's bodies but i
totally see what you guys are saying 100
like the woman will not die by having a
baby and being pregnant for nine months
the baby will die and if we want to
maximize good
the challenge is does the state then say
you know you're going to sacrifice for
nine months and you know have this as
part of you for the rest of your life
but at least two people survive in the
long run it's
yeah tough questions man i think the
other thing is um sometimes what gets
mixed into this conversation is like
there's two questions about the the
the act itself and then kind of the
moral guilt
of
the person who participates in the act
and i certainly believe that your moral
guilt
participating in the act i'm talking
about abortion could be severely
mitigated if we're talking about a child
who's you know and is being taken
advantage of by the abortion industry as
well so that's sort of like a different
discussion about about um the woman and
her own moral guilt and and the levels
and and mitigating circumstances but but
they're still just the question of the
act itself and what it
this this
this this uh life that's being killed is
it a life that's the question and are
you directly killing it and is it ever
okay to directly kill into human life
that's that's the question one last
question on this before we go to the
next story if we develop a technology
that can take a uh you know fertilized
egg even you know day one
this is a question i always have as well
if it's the point of viability if the
point of violet viability becomes uh day
one day you know minute one we can take
it and put it into some kind of machine
or technology that will allow it to live
would would would you uh would you guys
accept that humanism well
it is to a certain extent it's a very
huxley question right so the question
becomes then um
whose responsibility is this child are
we going to be
manufacturing parentless orphans in
order to the state wards of the state is
this what we're doing because the state
does
an amazing job right now raising orphans
right they do really just such stellar
work
um it's gorgeous you know we've seen the
results of this
uh of course it's spectacular
just a teeny weensy bit right um so
we've seen that so my question with with
this because this has been something
that i've considered as well
who raises the children
who who gets to tell them what to do who
teaches them sex ed who teaches them
whether or not to you know castrate
themselves because they think they
should be something else and are we
going to create a class of citizens
that are responsible to the state that
the state is responsible for you know
what is this like this weird
stormtrooper thing we've got going well
you know for adoption maybe they can be
put up for adoption but who's who's
going to adopt this is just just real
quick i want to get your guys thought on
this if you know women uh in any so
let's let's take two two forms of this
question one is if a woman gets pregnant
through any circumstance and then she
says oh i'm gonna place the baby into
you know
proto future development and then the
doctors transplant it it survives
would you be okay with that and the
second question is if a woman was forced
through rape and they said we're sorry
this happened to you but we can take the
baby out and help and it'll survive and
grow in this external process how would
you feel about that i want to mention
one thing in um when i last checked the
statistics in 2019 there were actually
twice as many couples on the waiting
list to adopt than there were abortions
that happened in the country that year
so i do think there would be people
willing to adopt but as for this this
theological i'm curious what what your
answer is here right i'll jump on but
it's i thought you're gonna give your
answer now you're saying yeah no no no i
want yours i want to see your question
um no no i mean i have an answer but i
just wanted to interject with that
before we got into it so the the
scenario is a woman is raped child is
conceived there's an option though to
remove the child and it will grow into
your face and put the child in like an
artificial womb yeah
i mean if the other option is is killing
the child then i certainly would prefer
the artificial lume scenario let's say
the other option is just saying no
abortion you can't you have to have the
baby
should the woman be like no you can't
make me do this i never chose this
should we go with artificial womb or i
think there's a there's a complicated
well there's a complicated moral
question here for a few reasons i mean
firstly
would this be something that was 100
effective or would it pose a risk to the
life of the child and then if it is
my answer to my answer to this question
would be that there are um that's
fantastical this is okay yeah this is
this is a technology that it hasn't
developed there's nothing like it that
exists and so
my response here is that there are you
know gray-haired theologians with beards
much better and longer than mine who can
sort of stroke them all day and come up
with much better answers to this
question than i ever could i'm not sure
and that's who i would defer to if they
come to come on i do think it's kind of
an interesting question because
obviously we've talked recently even
about you know ivf uh and this idea
people keep talking about renting wombs
even though that's surrogacy
yes yes but i mean more a slang has been
this room uh womb rental that has a kind
of like plagued twitter where people are
arguing about this and not just
surrogacy but also like you know talking
about when it's just for instance from a
donor and also from the original person
and what are the ethics of this and
obviously well surrogacy is prostitution
except you get screwed for nine months
okay
well i was gonna say i mean i've met
some surrogates and it's been a very
interesting conversation especially when
you know meeting one one girl who uh was
a surrogate and the the baby had some
sort of a defect and the people who were
using the surrogate wanted her to abort
her he was a kid and she didn't want to
abort the kid and then when she gave
birth the baby was just taken from her
and she doesn't know what happened to
the child and i've had this story i've
spoken to her about it so it is an
interesting thing but this idea of
transhumanism is two things i don't
think it's going to happen like you
think where there's just a slab and
we're taking these rare rape victims
because i think we always use this very
niche argument of like could we create a
technology where if there's this rare
time even let's say a mom is dying from
cancer and the dad wants to keep the
baby and we could take the baby out and
grow the baby in this artificial womb
you know in many ways it sounds amazing
in ethical places in an ethical nation
but all i see right now is the movement
for that technology so that men can get
pregnant and that's what i've seen with
this trans this trans woman they say
trans women will give birth so i don't
see us moving towards an ethical
development of technology in this world
for the basis of trying to do what's
right i see us for trying to go outside
the design of humanity whether you're a
christian the design of god or you're
not a christian the biological
mechanisms that create a stable species
i don't think that we are developing
things for the right motives so i'd have
to say it's not even theological for me
i say no let's let's see i think the
story real quick the interesting thing
to me is i think we're just looking for
what the right answer is in every
circumstance right
we're looking for the kantian
categorical imperative i just real quick
i
it is an interesting question but the
thing is
developing this technology where uh
hypothetically you could you could put a
a child of the very early stages in into
like an artificial womb i think it's
it's good to
develop that kind of technology for the
the situation were talking at the
beginning which is in a medical
emergency um to to be able to be able to
do that but then you you realize that
there would be these abuses where now
it's kind of just a convenience thing
let's take the child out and put in the
artificial womb and that's that's a bad
thing and that's the thing about
technology is it would turn into that
instantly yeah women would be like well
why should i ruin my body for this when
we can put in an article well we saw
that right like kim kardashian had
babies via surrogate another thing
okay i just want to say even even
intuitively when we look at this
potential technology this hypothetical
device
no one would argue that it would be
better for a child to develop in an
artificial womb rather than within the
body of their own mother so at the very
least there would need to be some kind
of justification the likes of which you
laid out these scenarios
of creating motherless orphans would be
i think that that is really something
that hasn't been explored
um to not know your mother in that sense
we have not seen a human being who
doesn't know their mother in that sense
and i think that we would end up with uh
something a little along the lines of a
sociopathic crazy person let's pull up
this next story from law and crime aclu
sues alabama attorney general over
devastating new law making medical care
for transgender youth a felony it's a
lie i love how they call it care yeah
that's why i i know right right off the
bat uh we also have this out of missouri
missouri proposes legislation to
prohibit gender transitions for minors
um
yeah this is important thing here they
call it medical care
and um i think there's a framing issue
here that at the very least suggest this
country is totally fractured under uh
by moral framework medical care to the
left is a 12 year old biological male
says i don't feel right so they say okay
we're going to give you surgeries which
could you know permanently alter damage
your body or restrict your body in some
way that we we we do that for only
gender ideology-based circumstances well
and abortion
well so you know what what i mean is on
the right it's very clear this is
child abuse yeah on the left it's
affirmation and medical care the issue i
take with this is just um if if a 12
year old boy said i'm dysmorphic and i
need to cut my hand off
we would not say well for the sake of
the child we'll remove their hand but we
we are seeing young women get double
mastectomies
at
uh even at the age of 13 in some
circumstances we had i posted a study on
twitter about it so i i do want to point
out that framing but then just you know
generally open up the conversation to
what we're seeing with these uh you know
these states that are banning this and
then there are other states that are
going the other direction yeah you have
to define your terms
medical care specific like medical care
is a is a thing it's a specific thing
and medical care is is something that is
done to treat
um a a problem in the body it's to treat
a disease or a malformation or a lesion
or something like that and so then the
question is
is
is is puberty
a disease that has to be treated that's
the and that that's essentially what
we're hearing from the trans ideology
side of this they say that well you know
you the child that didn't consent to
puberty and so you have to put a puberty
blocker well puberty is not it's not a
disease it's a natural process in the
body well it's not just the body i mean
hormones wash over the brain and that's
how your brain becomes you know more
fully developed that's part of it as
well that's part of puberty is becoming
an adult it's not just a bodily
thing it's also yeah i mean it's the the
body of the brain as well yeah and so
this is horrible framing these people
are obviously perfectly happy to be
misunderstood as implying this is a law
which would say that a kid could not
receive a necessary procedure to save
their life because they're transgender
that's how this is framed what it should
say is
in alabama you are not allowed to give
children sex changes for some reason
some perverts are mad about that so uh
the interesting thing about medical care
is that i wonder uh does medical care in
a general sense include psychotherapy
well yeah well let me let me let me okay
can i make a point on that real fast i
just was just a simple question the
answer is yes we all agree and then my
point was in scandinavian countries they
don't do child sex changes they do
psychotherapy but in the united states
they argue that's conversion therapy and
wrong and shouldn't be allowed well i
was just going to say that the problem
we're seeing today is has nothing to do
with science and i think we should have
seen back in the day when the humanities
were usurped educationally it wasn't by
by accident we'd make fun of them like
oh do you want to go take a class to
where you discuss how you feel about an
author's book in the american dream in
great gatsby or do you want to study
engineering not realizing that the great
thinkers and the ideologues the people
who study the humanities and create
these ideas the philosophers etc that
are out there and even people that study
english as we as we look down upon them
they took a hold of the subjects that we
disregarded and they changed the
language they actually from the ground
up have redefined the ability to define
terms the average person doesn't know
what science is they don't really
understand engineering but they can read
a news article written for a fourth
grade level reader and so i i was
talking to a transgender antifa we were
talking about this earlier a trans-tifa
uh and satanist on on a
live
and the key thing is here and i noticed
this with every argument all we're
battling over then is words so we mock
english teachers like oh it's just
english we went to school for english
well currently the battle isn't actually
in science it's english it's defining
actually our dictionary and what words
mean in terminology even biology is
mostly just built up of terms and i mean
yes latin and whatnot but i asked him i
go i go the guy goes you know
legitimately there is fascistic genocide
of trans people all around this country
and you're defending it and i go
fascistic genocide where in the world do
you see that's just stick janus i'm ser
i said i want to know because you're
china well nobody but he said this
trans kids no but a trans kid that's
almost like pets right now but uh the
recipe is shanghai but he goes but he
goes yeah and i go where is this who
goes oh well in the texas laws and i'm
in texas i'm very familiar with the
texas trans laws right now and there's
no genocide happening so he goes on to
define and goes genocide i said what is
genocide man what is that and that's
what we have to ask them what do you
mean now by genocide because we have no
absolute truth he goes well
you know that that's taking kids away
from parent parents who who want to get
you know gender reaffirming surgery and
hormone therapy and you know and i'm
like that's weird for me because i
thought genocide involved killing and
all the genocidal maniacs and tyrants
over the years apparently wasted a lot
of resources they could have just you
see you know child protective services
and took the kids away for two weeks and
they would have done i guess the racial
cleansing that they desired but i go
well what are you talking about and then
he brings up the fact uh you know as per
mention that you know this is this new
thing called social murder and so this
idea of the fact that if you withhold
trans uh reaffirming i'm using their
words reaffirming surgery you are
leading to the increased suicide rate of
trans kids therefore your actions are
the murderous actions and your choice to
limit is murder and i'm not defending
this i'm i was sitting there mind blown
going
dude and the best part about this is i
got to ask i said when did you start
hormones he goes it saved my life it
saved my life he goes well 22. i go okay
so you're saying that hormone saved your
life at 22 i hope you were past puberty
by 22. so you're a 22 year old you
started taking estrodol and different
types of blockers and what not at 22.
now you're trying to tell me what a 9
year old should be doing buddy did you
see the did you see the article in the
washington post it was an op-ed by
a writer named corrine cohn who was
talking about how
i don't know what the pronoun is to use
in this case anyway um
corrine was saying that at
uh yeah here this is yeah this is a
story tim at 19
um
cohn had uh
was castrated this was intentional um
and then it turns out that actually
he would have been a gay man
and has never had a sexual experience um
when he talked you know talks to friends
and friends are very dismayed by this
and
in the in the article corrine talks
about how uh never having experienced
this you know
they don't really know what they're
missing and i just find this to be so
sad that we are taking
away the sexual futures of so many of
these of these kids
not just their reproductive futures but
any real chance at intimacy you know
they're giving up something that they
don't that they don't know they don't
understand and they're they're giving it
up for the rest of their lives and
that's why the way this is all framed
that this is um
you know this is we're infringing on the
rights of the child no none of these
laws are
restricting the child this is about
restricting you as the adult we're
saying that you that's correct can not
do that to a child
the idea that the child has like
that their rights are being infringed
upon because they're not being mutilated
is is horrific i just want to make one
other point too
elijah brought up the
words and the way that words are
manipulated i think this is really
important because we what we have to
understand is on the other side the same
side of this trans discussion we are so
behind we're playing catch-up right now
because the language is so totally
controlled by the left even to the
extent of every time we use the word
gender
we are actually assenting to the left's
framework that yeah that's correct that
word itself was that was introduced into
the language the way that it's used now
by the people who invented gender
ideology for the purpose of
mainstreaming it so and by a pedophile
specifically john money it's actually
really fascinating too the whole
language thing because um i was in the
arts for most of my most of my career
most of my adult life and i could see
this you know this starting and you know
artists started becoming arts activists
instead and it started being like oh
when you do when you write a play it
should be um
it should be not just art not just
aesthetic but there needs to be this
activist backbone to it and you could
see people changing the language
intentionally and it started you know we
had the whole pc thing don't say
you know black say african-american
don't say
you know i don't know woman say some
other stupidity yeah right
so
but i mean we saw this happen it's been
happening for a long time and at first
just like it is now with the whole
gender thing at first it was sold to us
with the idea of compassion behind it
right it's more compassionate to use
these terms um it makes other people
feel better it's not offensive if you if
you speak about it this way and we have
con consistently allowed ourselves to be
bludgeoned with this idea of the
compassionate way
to talk to people and we're still there
i want to just ask you know uh
it's a legitimate question that i know
will never get answered because the
response on the left will be like it's a
bad faith question
um if if a kid was uh there's general
body dysmorphia dysphoric disorder or
something like that uh i talked about
this on the joe rogan podcast with jack
dorsey if someone and they do they feel
like their fingers need to be removed
they feel like their hand is transabled
this is a thing
yeah it's it's it's like general body
dysmorphic disorder something like that
would we then say for the health and
safety of the child we will remove their
perfectly functioning hand and the other
question on top of that is
we've seen
young girls get double mastectomies at
the age of even 13.
uh again i posted this on twitter
there's a study that was done in 2018
looking at the the results of you know
the quality of life
would we give a 13 year old boy large
breast implants if he said that they
would make him feel better and he was
depressed i think overwhelmingly most
parents even parents who want to affirm
their kids they'd probably look at that
and think twice and be like wait a
minute this doesn't seem right because
breast implants are not typically
associated with someone
seeking to uh like a young boy who's
feeling you know depressed and even a
young girl wouldn't have double d's or
something like that but i'm wondering at
what point we actually start seeing this
yeah so obviously at the present moment
the left would at the very least pretend
to be horrified by the idea of removing
a child's pinky because they've decided
that they don't want to have it at an
early age but if you ask any grown man
what would you rather have happened
would you rather have lost your pinky
finger as a child or would you rather
have lost the ability to fully develop
reproductively as a child any man would
tell you he would rather have lost his
pinky it's not even a question well hold
on there maybe but if you don't go
through puberty you you don't develop
that uh no that's my point well so so
if you ask someone who is has been um
had their gonads removed
this article describes it as gonad
destruction
before the heavy metal band
destruction before before puberty
they're not going to know what they lost
and they're not going to desire things
they haven't developed desire for i
don't know about that i think they'll be
they'll look at healthy married couples
and say i wish i could have had
something like that because there's
nothing i can agree with
this has been you just brought up john
money and this is yeah so we
we have a case study in this and um i
was like john money did that he's the
guy who invented gender ideology and he
did that to a young
boy a baby baby uh castrated a young boy
um
and told they told the parents to raise
the boy as a girl
and but it didn't the girl identity
didn't take hold because he's not a girl
so eventually they even
switch back yeah that was even even with
hormones killed himself later in life
yeah him and his brother both and the
brother the bothered and he performed
sexual experiments on the mobile he was
a as well he was a disgusting pervert on
everything but this is this is actually
an argument uh the left counters with
that uh it proves gender id uh gender
identity is inherent in a person right
that even though this person who didn't
choose to went through this
later in life they said no i am male and
always was the left argues that
certainly there are people who are who
are born male or female and then later
come to realize they have an alternate
gender identity well what the left i
mean sex is inherent a person does have
a sex gender is a completely nonsensical
term that was first developed by the man
who performed this sick sexual
experiment on children it was a complete
failure but he reported it as a success
it was printed in medical textbooks as
a success and as a matter of policy in
many hospitals as a result of his lies
many boys who underwent botched
circumcision were transitioned as
infants yeah that was messy yeah and i
i've heard that claim from from the
other side saying oh no that john money
actually proves that we're right but no
that if gender is determined partially
by society and environment and
everything then and that's what john
money believed he's the guy who came up
with this stuff
then this should have worked and it
didn't so he actually disproved his own
theory in this in this horrific
years-long experiment that he ran on
these kids the thing about gender the
definition up there i mean
originally gender is a linguistic term
that refers to to words like words have
gender masculine or feminine and john
money is the one who said that oh no
people have gender too people have a
gender and a sex yes
but you notice something else because
they said that people have a gender and
a sex and they're two different things
and that's and that's what they went
with for for decades and now they're
kind of collapsing the distinction again
and they're actually they've actually
gotten away from that and now they're
now they're basically saying that gender
and sex are the same thing because a
trans woman is a woman's exactly the
same thing as a woman they they will not
allow anymore that a quote trans woman
is um is a male they'll say a trans
woman is a female so that's what they're
they've gotten rid of the distinction
themselves and they're enshrining this
in law i mean now the the civil rights
act of 1964
protects gender identity in the same way
that it protects you know
women that wasn't that was amanda
nationally well it's not like they
haven't gone back and rewritten the
amendment but the executive orders that
biden signed essentially do that well in
uh
most states
have actually passed uh these these
civil rights amendments that say gender
identity is protected as well the
question then is how do you define
gender identity and this is where things
get more difficult in new york for
instance it's defined as a person's
self-expression
because you know i pulled up the word
gender on wikipedia and it says the
range of characteristic characteristics
pertaining to femininity and masculinity
and differentiating between them the
challenge is the
modern left ideology suggests that
address is not inherently feminine or
masculine in which case it's not a part
of gender
so if you have somebody who has long
hair and wears makeup and you know wears
bras and female clothing that isn't
according to their own ideology
inherently feminine and gendered in
which case
the whole thing starts to become
illogical i suppose
how does how does a child know they're
transgender if a little girl says she
likes playing with trucks and the color
blue
they might say will you like things boys
like no because girls can like trucks in
the color blue same so they're trying to
have it both ways they're both telling
us that gender stereotypes are a problem
and need to be abolished and that you
can tell what your gender identity is
based on which gender stereotypes you
adhere to
and both things can't be true i i really
do think that um for the most part it's
not that they're trying to have both
technically that's the case it's that
there is no truth but power to these
people so any circumstance in which they
can assert something to gain power they
do and that's why they often contradict
themselves then we sit here as logical
beings trying to understand the map
they've created in terms of logic and it
makes no sense to us yeah in breaking
down sexual boundaries is fantastic if
you're in a position of power and rather
than having a healthy functioning
society you'd rather have one where
people look up to and they're very easy
to control and the best way to break
down sex relationships the best way to
break uh break down the family after
you've already done things like
made contraceptives widely available and
socially acceptable is to go for the
actual direct definition of sexuality
and completely collapse it so that the
sexes have no hope of ever developing
any understanding of how they should
relate to each other from their society
right so let's talk about what's
happening with um with kids here because
we have the story from fox news new
jersey sample lesson plans push videos
for fifth graders on graphic sex related
content um i mean this was the stuff
released by lips of tick tock right was
this the the yeah well she started it
yeah i just wanted to give her credit
yeah yeah so
it seems like we're seeing an inversion
almost of what florida is doing where
florida's like hey look you know
third grade and below it's it's hits
hands off after you know fourth grade
and up you can have these conversations
without parental consent which i also
think it's still kind of crazy because
parents should be signing off on you
know curriculum and knowing what's going
on but now we're seeing uh schools
having uh graphic sex related content
for for even fifth graders i think this
is a great um this is a great argument
for chris ruffo's whole transparency and
education thing which i which i love
this idea that curriculum needs to be
posted before the beginning of the year
so you can see what's going on i like it
for this reason and i like it just so
that i would know
what my kid is up to and i can like help
study what's interesting in new york is
you have the unelected governor kathy
holcol
pushing for um you know similar kinds of
stuff as new jersey
thoroughly opposed to the
parental rights and education bill
in florida and you have um andrew
giuliani
who is also running for governor saying
that he's interested in having a
parental rights and education bill in
new york i think it's going to come down
to i think a lot of that's going to
really come up in that in that in that
in that uh what do you call it race in
that race
i was going to say with this stuff is
what's so insane is that um with talking
to the kids about this stuff i've looked
at some of these lesson plans of course
just out of educational responsibility
not because i wanted to learn and in the
way that they actually teach the kids
about sex is so inaccurate it's
absolutely crazy so you thought porn was
a bad educator for children
it is kind of crazy they're now talking
about uh they start they're not calling
people kids anymore and they're not
using the difference between adults and
children but they're using this phrase
called young people which is this idea
of children so that's the new hot phrase
that they're using young people and this
idea of taking away man and woman old
and young adult and child and everyone's
a person x like a latinx we're all vague
and we're all a person and there's this
level of maturity i know we talked about
this before the show but uh some of
these educational sites that have porn
on them to teach kids about the websites
you can check them out they're cartoon
porn and unless you got some really
weird fetishes i don't think you're
gonna get stumbled i don't think you're
going to really like them a lot but you
go to click in and it asks you if you're
in a if you have it says by federal law
you have to be 18 to enter the site then
asks if you're mature enough and when
you get in there the lessons on sex for
kids are so strange if somebody had told
me that's what sex is like the one i saw
up front was they were like sometimes
you get an erection you get horny and
the guy's penis was the size of his
torso it was like it was like this big
and i'm going okay i understand
exaggeration and art but if we're going
to teach kids about
accuracies of sex why are you using
cartoons with penises this four feet
long that's very weird take a look at
this story it's from timcast.com
maryland department of education will
require pre-k students to learn about
gender identity and expression the
state's health curriculum curriculum
aims to examine how racism impacts
sexual identity by middle school i want
to break this way how racism impacts
gender identity by middle school
so hold on i got i got a bone to pick
with this your timcast.com is it a four
foot long bone will require
when you actually pull up the document
it actually has on it uh
pre-kindergarten through high school
first july 2020 to june 2021 it sounds
like they're already doing it and now i
have questions about the website but the
website is is linked through the
maryland.gov portal so this is coming
out of maryland's public school website
this document talking about
pre-kindergarten through high school and
what they're going to be teaching these
kids
i don't think that it's in it it's a
it's planned opposition to what's
happening in florida i think what
florida is is in effect of opposition to
what they've already been doing yeah and
it was already happening in florida too
and this is uh by the way talking about
the history of things i mean
comprehensive sex education
that started with with alfred kinsey was
another pedophile and uh and and
expressly wanted to and believe wanted
to sexualize children believe that
children are sexual literally from birth
and it's a whole story there's totally
horrifying but comprehensive
comprehensive sex education goes back to
him it starts there and so it is a from
the beginning an effort to sexualize
children to sexualize them also kind of
based in this kind of circular way on
the idea that children are already
sexual from birth and the thing about
that's so insidious because we see that
oh they're teaching this stuff to
preschoolers we find it so shocking and
it is
i mean it's horrifying but it's actually
not
surprising
because well of course they want to get
to the kids that young because when
you're that when you're four years old i
mean these are the kids who believe you
know in santa claus they
they think that spider-man is real so
at that age psychologically they cannot
distinguish they actually cannot
distinguish between between reality and
fantasy if you go to a four-year-old
and you say to the four-year-old
superman doesn't exist they won't even
know what you mean by that doesn't mean
anything doesn't exist what do you mean
i can see him on tv i know he exists and
so that's
the left's ideas about especially about
gender are so
ridiculous and insane that they have to
get to the kids that young
at an age where they where they don't
have the mental capacity
to see it for the absurdity that it is
well and if you can indoctrinate him
that young then you get them you know
potentially for life what's funny to me
is uh that's what i was told growing up
about christianity
was that the church goes it goes tries
to get the kids so that they grow up
indoctrinated in the church and dogma
and things like that and now we're
i i gotta say it is fascinating to see
that when when it comes to critical race
theory gender ideology and the general
world cult it seems that they're doing a
lot of what the left claimed the right
did a long time ago like they're arguing
the other side does it but they're doing
it and the difference is
so yeah you hear that argument about
that that's what that's what what
religions do and the left makes that
argument it's actually interesting
because what they're essentially
admitting is that gender ideology is a
religion and so that part i agree with
them at least we have it in the right
category it's actually a religious point
of view but the difference is that um
with christianity
you you can ask really difficult
questions
and in fact for most christians who are
informed like they want to have that
conversation let's talk about it why do
i believe in the bible why do i believe
in god let's have the conversation it's
it's great um with gender ideology
though this is why they have to get to
the kids very young
it collapses under the slightest
scrutiny they cannot answer like any
questions about it
ask them to find their terms they can't
do it and so that's that's well that's
why they resort to insults instead right
right
it's like like i asked um you know look
whenever this topic comes up we
invariably uh mention the jack dorsey
rogan podcast because i you know this
conversation was about censorship but i
said to jack your rules are inherently
biased and he said no they aren't and i
said you have a misgendering policy that
enforces the left's worldview on what
misgendering means the right things
misgendering is if someone is
biologically male or female you use
inverted pronouns and the left thinks if
someone chooses to use pronouns you
don't use them you've decided to enforce
what the left thinks i asked would you
enforce these rules he was like well
look we do this because there's high
suicide rates we're trying to protect
people and i said sure but you don't do
that for anyone else's suicidal you
don't say you can't disparage police
officers or dentists you don't say that
you can't disparage people who are who
are dysmorphic in terms of anorexia or
bulimia yeah soldiers have an insane
combat veterans have an insanely high
suicide rate nobody says that means we
can't criticize us
foreign on youtube youtube wait wait
criticizing us foreign policy is a
bannable offense because of content
actually technically it can be monetized
if you talk about ukraine or russia the
wrong way now that that's absolutely
true the rules actually say i i'm pretty
sure youtube says you'll be banned for
disparaging someone based on their
veteran status yeah but that's different
that's different that's not um
if you're disparaging someone for the
veteran status that's different from
criticizing the broader ideologies
that's the point right right you're
saying hey like i've heard people say
this all the time should have never been
in that war you know and i i've
literally watched this not only on on
youtube but in every social media
something to this regard of going yeah
you know imagine your brother died in
afghanistan and then you see now the
pull out especially when we were leaving
and that the war they say was for
nothing and what do you feel about your
brother's death i mean that would be
something that i would say as a family
member imagine i'm heartbroken and i'm
sitting there and someone's railing onto
it it might put me in a position where i
would feel unstable emotionally does my
life matter but i also think that the
key about the trans thing you have to
realize is like i i this is gonna sound
crazy to some people but i think you
can't talk about this without being
somewhat theological or at least if
you're not theological metaphysical you
could put it into this there is a
depopulation agenda and it seems that we
always prioritize the social issues that
lead to the population it's like whether
it's the trans identity whether it's and
we target when they're young
specifically in puberty we're not
fighting for transsexual adults we're
fighting for transgenderism am i a state
of mind specifically in kids it's for
abortion in the womb it's for climate
change and reducing our emission and the
amount of people in the carbon footprint
it's about reducing our intake
biosynthetic meat about not having
access to things when you look at the
amalgamation of all of the targets of
the the global agenda i'd say the
western global agenda uh specifically eu
united states the five eyes et cetera so
when you go there it all seems hell bent
on somehow bringing this down and then
that this is not antithetical to what
the actual elites talk about very
regularly in davos and also too just
openly like on public forums and i hate
to be like the bill gates guy but i just
let people talk about there's too many
people there's too many and there's just
not i know but yeah no i totally i agree
with you so yeah that's where the social
issues go what is the common link the
common link is about making us less
accessible to resources to ideas to
expand to grow and to shrink but
shrinking the population i would say um
perhaps these pieces line up but i would
also be careful because
that's the territory where you're you're
you're
far removed from the average person
doesn't understand what's going on it's
very very simple to go to a middle-class
working family and say you know would
you be in support of your 13 year old
son getting large breast implants and
then being like excuse me get out of my
house it's much more it's much different
if you go to them and say let me break
down very quickly for you this deep
population agenda why i think they're
doing these things this is this is the
issue um you know it was really funny i
went on candace kennedy's owens show
earlier and she was fantastic by the way
but she mentioned uh we're talking about
alex jones and how
you know a lot of what he says might be
too colorful for regular people to
understand when he you know i mentioned
that the media comes out and says you
know he's yelling the frogs are gay or
whatever and she was like but he was
right i mean not overtly about frog
being gay but that you know there's a
chemical that was you know causing
problems and you know for frogs and i
said right a chemical called atrazine
was reportedly uh interfering with the
endocrine systems of frogs and alex
jones yelled out or turned the frogs gay
or whatever and uh the media takes that
to poison the well so i try to be
careful with messaging but i get what
you're saying i think it's it's more
tactful to just approach the issues
individually because i think most
regular working people agree that
individually these things are all are
all issues we're facing well it is
interesting i think with the climate
change specifically because
um there is this uh you you guys have
heard extinction rebellion
met a lot of those guys before very
funny so they're very opposed to anybody
having children right i hope they don't
i hope they you know maybe they don't
have them but um but that's sort of the
ideas that like people should not have
children that it's a drain on the
earth's resources and all of this but
it's like the less people we have the
less resources we're going to have
because there's going to be less people
to do the work to gather the resources
or to create the new things and this is
actually well this would be fair real
quick they're saying
the amount of say
oil in the ground will be consumed by a
billion people but a million people will
consume a you know order of magnitude
several order magnitude several orders
have mentioned less they're not saying
that they're you know
like i understand what you mean there'll
be less refined resources but their
argument is yeah it's so rare we can't
even
so firstly what you're saying is
verified by basically all of the
statistics that we have on population
growth and wealth world population has
exploded in global poverty has decreased
significantly in that time human beings
have a remarkable ability not only to
provide for themselves but for others as
well and so the left has this way of
looking at resources which is very fixed
pie and very childish they think that
there's just been this fixed number of
resources that we've had access to from
the beginning of time and we've been
slowly dwindling them down
failing to comprehend the fact that as
new people with new minds come along
they find new ways to use what we
already have and ways to use what we
thought was useless in the past
ben shapiro made an excellent point i
saw this viral video where he was asked
about climate change and why he didn't
think it was an emergency i think he
gave a very verbose answer but his uh
his ending point
his last point was he doesn't think it's
a disaster because the um the
predictions don't account for mitigation
factors meaning you know they look at
these these charts say oh we're going to
have uh 10 feet of water rise in a
hundred years
burying cities 200 feet and you know in
the next thousand and it's going to wipe
out all these cities and it's like right
right and you're not accounting for the
fact that human adaptation happens right
which you you go back to that famous
story about horse manure in new york
you're familiar with this one
yeah they said at the turn of the
century we are going to be buried under
horse manure in new york city because
there's too many horses and too much
manure well they kind of are yeah well
they're buried under human
but then they invented the car and all
of a sudden the horse manure problem
changed now i i do think there there's
there's an obvious mathematical equation
that the planet can only sustain so many
human beings and i don't know uh how
many how i don't know what that number
is i don't think we've got there yet but
we're not close i'm not entirely sure i
agree i think you know a lot of people
talk about there's not that many humans
the planet is almost entirely empty it's
like yes but are there enough humans to
disrupt a sim a large chemical process
say in the north atlantic current
my issue is i do think population
density is a huge problem new york is a
large concrete block that can't sustain
itself and it creates massive pools of
waste and insane yeah that's but that's
the problem is is the way humans are
choosing to congregate but you could
take the entire population the globe and
put them in texas and they'd still have
they're still a good amount of space
it's just that we you know you have
these vast expanses of land that aren't
used and we choose to to pile into
cities and so on so that's but that's
true but consider this um
you know you could take the entire you
said the entire population of the planet
pilum in texas right
yeah but uh real estate everybody would
have an idea how much ammonia
needs to be produced to disrupt uh the
you know the the oceans ecosystem or or
a natural
cycle of like the ecosystem on this
planet it we don't need to flood the
planet with ammonia we don't need to but
or you know other chemicals but humans
do produce waste products and it's not
just you know the human literal waste
products it's uh chemical byproducts and
plastics so my concern is the amount of
waste produced by humans to disrupt the
entire planet is probably not as it's
not going to be like you know 10 percent
of the planet surface of garbage
destroys the planet it could be 0.01
causes of chemical disruption which
disrupts the ecosystem we've seen things
like dead zones in the gulf dead zones
in oceans where there's no oxygen and no
no life can can can live and there's the
north pacific garbage gyre the garbage
gyres are really really bad yeah and uh
this has an impact on
life cycles so that's the entire planet
like
that for example is not a population
problem per se it's just what the people
are choosing to do it's like it's like
you know these agree you could go to uh
some of these rivers in asia are just
moving garbage dumps people just
throwing
uh their their uh waste products into
the river meanwhile like in america
we're blaming ourselves because of our
plastic straws or whatever and now we
got paper straws and they suck right
exactly exactly they have masks
everywhere right they're everywhere like
the mask thing they they choke the trees
the way plastic bags used to then you
got other parts of the world and it's
like they're the rivers are literally
just like conveyor belts for trash out
to the ocean but that's that's uh
people are choosing to join you don't
have to do that but scale it up but now
we have microplastics in our bodies
eliminate human technological byproducts
there is a point at which humans fart
themselves to death yeast does it in in
in a bottle but the same thing is not
saying we're there i don't know where it
will be but mathematically it's it's
obvious that it exists now my point on
top of this is so i think pollution is a
is a problem i think we should be aware
of that and do our best to mitigate that
to live as clean as possible minimize
our entropy maximize our entropy but
also in the process we should be
colonizing other planets we should be
doing scientific advancement we should
be launching space stations i think we
should be doing all of that stuff i
think we should be totally like
using the resources we have to
bust out of the solar system why because
we are a race of explorers and
uh foreign
a real answer fun is a real answer
humanity can be wiped out by a single
comet right now if we had a but a small
space station on mars the humans on mars
would be would not be impacted by a
crisis on earth in the same way making
us more resilient and more prone to
survival that's a good reason too
and fun can actually say i actually
prefer the fun answer i think that's
because just from up front if you try to
argue that like from a practicality
standpoint we have to build colonies on
mars i mean mars is is the
what would be required for the for our
planet to be more inhospitable than mars
i mean it's like uh at that point
probably humanity no longer exists
anyway i i actually couldn't we like
mine the asteroid belt that would be
cool and that's the thing i i actually
i'm in favor of colonizing
um the solar system if we can not really
because it's practically makes a lot of
practical sense but just because that's
what humanity is meant to do you're
meant to just right to strive for the
horizons and i think when you stop doing
that then you're basically giving up on
human civilization i'm against it to be
completely honest i'm so in favor
because you're
anti-colonialism yes actually because i
don't want to i don't want the rock
monsters to have to identify with a new
species should we be reaching out like
we you know we had the exploration age
and we were when you had people on ships
and they were going across uncharted
waters and we don't have that anymore so
where do you go now when you look at the
globalist amounts of money that it's
taking to fund this stuff i bring up
this problem with it and this is an
interesting perspective that i think
really deviates if you hold like a
christian worldview or an atheist
worldview that i think we have to
understand because obviously if you're
eschatologically you know sound in some
way even if you are in another religion
but specifically christianity which is
the major religion in the united states
you know there's this understanding that
at the end times it says that people
will be saying like life how always has
been and always will be people will be
given in marriage they will be trading
when when god comes to judge the world
in that way then there's an
understanding that judgment comes when
god comes to judge the world and the end
of the age the end of the world is in
god's hands and we're not going to just
get struck with a comet however if you
don't believe that then i totally even
understand what you're saying because
that is a total probability like
scientifically what you're saying by the
way makes 100 logically but i want to
make this point though about the
colonization is sometimes i think that
humans we we have this uh big man
syndrome where i agree with the
exploration and my wife was really
having a difficult time i've been
watching like cave accidents and she was
like why are people going into caves and
and this is where i would concede your
point i said dude exploration and this
idea of of pushing the boundaries is
part of the human spirit that god gave
us but
going into space is sort of a
taxpayer-funded burden that i feel in
many ways i mean the private the
privatization of it what's happening now
is still very interesting as we're
moving in that but overall it's been
very costly and i've always wondered
those resources and that movement with
going to mars almost seems like a
distraction that we talk about you know
he's going into space and it's like i
get it we have problems here i don't
know but i don't think those actually
solve yeah but when we but
when we start exploring there's a couple
points that have to be made
yes technological advancements that came
from taxpayer-funded space exploration
and the money is spent doesn't leave
anywhere it's cycled into the economy
and it's good for the economy that
people are working on these technologies
often when we have factories machining a
lot of these parts they remain and can
machine other parts so technological
technological advancement is just good
across the board also it lets us dream
it it gives us a it gives us a place to
put our our fantasies and our imaginings
and our hopes for the future here's a
you're asking what problem does it solve
well i think our our most fundamental
problem in our society right now is is
like
malaise and despair people have just
given up on life given up on life having
any meaning and i'm not saying that
space exploration solves that but it is
it's a it is it helps anyway in that
regard i mean when was the last time
that the united states of america were
like united over together over something
good that happened celebrating a good
thing that happened when's the last time
that ever that that we had the united
states probably the moon landing i was
gonna say since chauvin got convicted uh
that how was the last time
i really think the moon landing the moon
landing was the last time that the
united states had a good thing that
everybody together was cheering um and
so
not even caitlyn jenner no no but the
argument
the argument there the argument they're
matt is this is it and i and i want to
say this people even argue whether that
happened or not i don't have a strong
opinion on the moon landing but i will
say it definitely well i know i'm saying
people just really did happen people in
the chat are going to argue i'm saying
when you say that i'm saying but i'm not
going to argue about i don't think so i
think they're mostly going to say it
happened okay well i don't know i've
been seeing movement what i'm saying is
i don't want to get stuck on that i want
to say yes i agree that moment was a
total unifying factor and absolutely
amazing what space exploration appears
to be today is number one the
militarization of the outer hemisphere
is number two it seems to be not a
national idea of a space race of us
coming together and having a national
unity it seems to be who can afford a
ticket to go out into the solar system
and actually get out there it seems more
like a like another rich man's ploy to
escape earth
new technology always exists for the
wealthy and also we had you know we had
a government-funded space program that
has now brought us to a point where we
have private citizens who are able to
further space research that's cool
that's part of it that's part of the
capitalist undertaking i'm not going to
win anybody over here i know that but
you're definitely not going to yeah i'm
shameless nailed it i mean imagine being
like microwaves so you need to cook your
food 10 minutes faster rich people buy
the stupidest thing just use this stuff
well eventually everybody gets it but i
want to ask a an interesting question
with the last few minutes we have before
super chats um space travel gentlemen
i believe everyone here is religious
assuming aliens exist should we not
should should humans travel the stars to
spread the gospel of jesus christ to
aliens to other planets to other worlds
you know what's interesting about that
do you want to go ahead yeah well i so
this is actually actually an interesting
question and there's a podcast i love
listening to it's called jimmy aiken's
mysterious world i'm going to shout it
out he is a catholic apologist he's very
brilliant and he'll talk about questions
like this which is not something you
commonly get so very unique phil's a
great niche he did a whole episode on on
the possibility of aliens and
extraterrestrial life that i would
really suggest the audience check out if
they're interested in in that kind of
question but i i personally i don't know
that i would have much to uh to say
about that i'm not sure the theological
implications of extraterrestrial life
what do you guys think what if they
already know
yeah wouldn't it would it be the
craziest thing if like we land on this
planet and we walk out and the first
thing they say is i'd like to
have you heard about our lord and savior
jesus christ i mean the other thing too
is it it tells us in the gospel that the
way to spread your faith is through kind
acts and
by living that faith
yeah i mean c.s lewis talked a lot about
this and wrote you know wrote science
fiction
and so he even speculated about because
we believe in the christian faith that
we're a fallen
species could you have if if if there's
another planet out there separated
by light years and galaxies could they
even potentially be unfallen maybe they
had their own choice they made the right
choice and then what are the
implications of us kind of mixing do we
do we
almost become sort of like the serpents
in the garden now we're where we are the
the the tempters
so it's an interesting question i don't
know what the answer to that is it's
kind of interesting to speculate but you
guys ever watch american dad sadly so uh
roger the alien lives of them but you
know stan of course they're they're
christian and so there's a story arc
where um the the the apocalypse happens
and the rapture happens
and then when you know all the good
people are raptured jesus is on earth
and he sees roger the alien he goes ugh
one of my father's side projects oh gosh
out of those funny jokes no it is that
is amazing do you believe in
extraterrestrials i do yeah all right
yeah absolutely i mean to me it just
seems like a
the classic argument i find really
compelling which is just like a
mathematical certainty basically when
you when you when you consider the
expanse the just the the sheer
unimaginable size of the universe you
got 100 billion galaxies with 100
billion
stars in each one and then each
surrounded by planets it's just the idea
that that the entire thing is empty of
life to me is a it's just an absurdity
and i don't see any reason to assume
that but i think that if you someone who
says that they think it's all empty it's
like the it's almost like the burden of
proof is on you in a way that that's
that's the more absurd
in the opposite direction i hear what
you're saying i think for me i i would
not eliminate it as a possibility but i
would say i would need to see some
evidence or proof that they exist
because the argument is often made there
are so many planets that could
potentially have life on them odds are
there must be life there but the problem
with that is first you're assuming that
life arising is an odds game rather than
an intentional act by a creative god
which is what i believe but even if it
is an odds game you're assuming that you
have some idea of what the odds are so
let's say there's a billion habitable
planets well what if odds are only one
in a billion then it would make sense
that earth is the only planet of his
life what if god intended to create life
on other planets yeah yeah exactly
certainly that's i think i i don't see
it as an odds game but i i here's the
way i look at it's like if you if you
walk into a a giant mansion with like
hundreds of rooms and you're just right
in the foyer and then you kind of look
around and say i think the whole place
is empty if you were to say that then
it's like then i'm going to say to you
well why are you assuming that it just
it seems like the most logical thing to
assume is that there's probably people
in this house somewhere but i think i
think they're totally unfurnished and
dusty and there's no shoes around and
everything's covered but all you but in
this area you've walked in but in this
analogy all you see is literally the
floor it's all you can see yeah
like what are we seeing or the tiles i'm
gonna say i'm not
your perspective actually because i mean
i think somebody might come and be like
extraterrestrials i know where you're
coming from i just feel like for my my
world view i genuinely believe that that
life was intentional and because of how
i believe the fallen nature of our of
our closed universe really is i believe
that the curse that god judges based off
of the action of man it would be unfair
to then judge that onto somebody else at
least that's intelligent now if there
was something unintelligent or some
smaller form of simpler life form
obviously even the curse of man passes
down to animals and lower life form here
so i guess that could exist however i
don't mock that because i do believe in
the supernatural which is even crazier
there's so many people that don't
believe in god think the supernatural
makes you a kooky guy but then they
believe in aliens so i'm not going to do
the opposite back and like i don't
believe it but i believe in the
supernatural i do believe there's
something else out there i just do not
believe it is physical and i believe the
physical was created here can i just
point out too that i think i i do think
it's strange that there are atheists who
believe in ghosts
yes and energy and stuff but here's the
thing you guys are talking about like
where this fallen that human humanity
has fallen i think it's really sort of
lucky that we were ejected from the
garden and that we discovered our free
will and i think it gives us a much
closer relationship with god to choose
that relationship as opposed to just
being you know the children in the
garden who are naked and innocent i
think it's
you know god gave us that free will
and now
we have the free will to love god fully
we had free will from from the beginning
but now we live more separated from god
because of the fall which is it's taking
us down a path away from aliens but but
i mean it's but it also i mean
we would have known jesus christ we
would have no
like we would not have this faith
well jesus it would just be it would be
like a knowledge it would not be a faith
jesus existed eternally so we would
still have jesus christ
there was no jesus christ in the garden
of eden there wouldn't have been a need
there wouldn't have been a need for for
a redemptive right saving act right i
think that would be a good thing i think
i don't i'd yeah i disagree but ask
questions
yeah i i actually i just want to clarify
a little bit because you brought up this
idea of calling into a house and you see
the fire and there's a lot of rooms
my point is not that i'm dismissing the
possibility or saying absolutely no
there's nothing out there it's just that
until i saw someone there had an
indication that there was someone there
i wouldn't assume that anyone else was
in the house well i think just the fact
that the house exists and there's so
many rooms is a pretty good it's not
proof but
you have a pretty good reason to assume
that there's probably
people in it somewhere so i think the
assumption that it's empty is the one
that needs
well i'm not even i'm not even
necessarily saying it's empty i'm just
saying i in order to believe in aliens i
think i would have to say yes i think
they're there and i'm not prepared to
say that given what i know so talk so
talking about the the intentionality and
god creates for a reason which of course
we all believe so then what i would ask
you guys is
we have all of these galaxies and solar
systems that we can't even see like we
we
we can't even look up at the sky and see
that oh it's a pretty light because the
light hasn't been reached yet and all
just just trillions of planets
everything why does any of that
exist maybe for us for it to be entire
entirely empty but it's maybe it's true
we will never see it or go anywhere near
it or know that it's there but it is
there maybe we will one day maybe it's
possible that it needs all of like that
all of that is needed to support earth
that's that's true though so i watched
this really excellent lecture by this uh
very christian scientist he drew an
interesting conclusion but what he said
was
jupiter is essentially a filter for the
solar system that its gravitational pull
helps protect the inner planets and that
the earth should be peppered with much
more space debris but jupiter protects
us and so he went on to explain how
we're actually quite fortunate that life
has arisen on earth but it's because of
the entirety of the solar system that
created this machine that we don't
realize in the in the long run
that um perhaps in the development of
life at whatever stage
you know one impact could have wiped out
all life like we already know with the
dinosaurs assuming that is the the
correct uh theory these days they change
it very often but jupiter protects us so
the shape of the solar system matters i
wonder if the rest of the universe
matters too it's all part of one big
machine i don't know i personally don't
think that uh
i agree with you matt that the expanse
of the universe i believe suggests life
probably exists somewhere else i think
so too based on similar conditions on
earth which we've witnessed and measured
on other planets
you know i hope to one one day humanity
will get there and we should totally go
check it out i hope i'm wrong on this
one in some ways because i being
somebody who's who really does love the
physical approach to these things it is
so interesting that with everything
we've put into space and everything that
we've tried to understand that we have
not found the viable forms of life we've
actually tried to look for and maybe
we're just way behind in our development
and our technology and and i and i i'm
ashamed in that in the fact that i do
believe in like it's good to study the
stars and understand paths and whatnot
but i also think i don't know going out
there just trying to find life on other
planets
the life has come here it's like the
navy pilots are seeing ufos all over the
place they're telling us about it
they're like hey guys look at those ufos
and we're all you know what
extraterrestrials what if the the
reality is
aliens have already come here
quite normally and boringly as say
tourists but they get stopped by
intergovernmental panels where like
humans do not know about this you cannot
come to this is one of my favorite
sci-fi things is when humans don't know
anything about extraterrestrials and
then like some bureaucratic government
somewhere else in the universe is like
just get rid of earth we got to put a
highway there yes i love that well of
course hackers guys
but it happens in other stuff too where
they're just like get rid of earth i
love it i love that stuff let me ask you
guys uh so i we have
we have uh we have launched chicken city
which of course i'm extremely proud of
one of the most super chatted shows in
the world already and uh do these
chickens know what's going on outside
the chicken coop they have no idea what
exists outside there they don't even
know what's going on i don't even know
about the disco party
they're confused by it what if we are
what if earth is a chicken coop
in essence
analogous to a chicken coop where aliens
know that we're here and they just sit
back and watch and they're live
streaming it you know i mean south park
did the the gag that aliens use earth as
a as a reality show sure
some super chats you know well what if
we're just a cherry in a bowl of cereal
it's the uh great zoo hypothesis to uh
fermi's paradox that maybe we are just a
great zoo for the universe and the
reason you know all these other great
civilizations talk to each other all the
time and then earth is just
entertainment for them so we're just
not not relevant and that's why they're
not getting back to us on our gold
record that we sent out right there
they're laughing at it they're just like
they sent us these weird naked pictures
they sent us lewd images
i think it's i think it's possible i
think it's i think
it's it's sort of depressing i always go
with the more depressing theory which is
that um which is that like maybe
civilization just reaches a point where
it can't progress anything you reach a
certain point where
self-destruction is inevitable fermi
paradox well well actually sheamus said
we were we were spitballing some ideas
and james had a great idea where it's
like the year is 22.70 and like some guy
travels to the future and everything's
the exact same yeah that's right and
they're like that was it yeah we stopped
yeah we stopped this is the peak of
technology there's nothing else
20 22 that was it huh they dropped the
iphone 12 and we're like well
nothing else to do i guess we're done
we're satisfied all right how about we
go to super chats
if you have not already my friend smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
subscribe to timcast.com we're gonna
have an excellent extra spicy members
only show over at timcast.com going up
at 11 p.m eastern but for now we will
read your super chats and see what you
have to say about our our crazy
conversation that we've been going
through
all right sean turner says lol live bird
poop drop on biden today was rolling on
the floor laughing that's just today i
thought it's happened before did you
guys know you guys saw this i only heard
about it coming libby mentioned it
that biden got pooped on it was kind of
funny yeah there's a little there's a
conspiracy around it right because it's
not clear if he was pooped i didn't see
the video with her really it looks like
pretty poopy does it okay oh yeah the
last time he pooped his pants allegedly
right that's what it was heard that
story yeah i mean i i don't know anymore
with him because it's almost like the
conspiracies are less bad than the
reality well can i ask you something
from your videos this is this is the sad
question right but would you think any
differently of him had he defecated in
his pants i'm serious would you would
you see him as any less competent than
you already do i'd see him as more
confident really thank you
just goes yeah i'm not trying to make my
own i guess i guess i guess my point is
people talk about this in in it's uh you
know it's it's gross
but the point is people are so ready to
believe it because whether it happened
or not it's not as if it would undermine
his credibility i'm sorry to say i mean
he's an old man who can't take care of
himself and he's leading the country he
gotta go that's depressing yeah yeah i'm
not i'm not even trying to make it
there were fact checks on that he looked
lost at the white house reception and
reuters was like he didn't he didn't
look lost at the white house reception
no he was just looking for this
secretary of the interior which he
clearly lost
he couldn't find her all right here we
go we got
sandy warren says just landed in
nashville this morning the rain
definitely wasn't something i was
expecting what sort of cultural content
were you guys looking to branch into as
an army guy i've been craving a
non-satire place for military content i
don't know if that's uh anything you
know we're looking at just yet
but in terms of cultural content and
nashville
uh we mentioned with john rich on the
show the other day that we were planning
on going to redneck riviera his venue on
saturday i think it's going to be
saturday afternoon i don't know the
exact time so for those that were
planning on being there because i'm
super excited it's gonna be fun we're
gonna we're gonna jam on his stage she's
got a downtown nashville uh show up in
the early morning and stay there all day
and then we'll figure out when we get
there i think it's gonna be in the
afternoon so it's gonna be super fun but
nashville's cool man
being from dallas i gotta say this to
all the nashville lights i don't know
what they're called nashvillonians
whatever you guys are bologna
i think that's a pastry i went out on a
monday night i mean i didn't drink or
anything because like i wasn't planning
on going out and doing anything crazy
that's popping more than any area in
dallas on a monday night like i walked
out and it was like party central like i
did i went out also monday night but i
was drinking and i had a great time i
went and grabbed a beer i just didn't
know that was like i didn't know mondays
were cool in nashville i think it's like
every i think
all right funny farm says matt you
surely inspired many as the country's
premier lgbt author do you have any tips
for someone who wants to contribute to
the market of children's books keep it
up you're my spirit animal
well um the daily wire is getting it's
our big announcement we're getting into
children's content so
um
get in touch with us i guess would you
be interested in a chicken city
children's show i think it sounds great
i don't think you need to change it to
make it a children's show just my kids
would watch that they would oh yeah like
the chicken parties like i hear from
parents they're like their kids are like
i want to see the chicken party and then
they'll donate and then the chicken
party happens and the chickens just go
nuts
i mean yeah
it's probably the you know chicken city
might save this world it's going to
unite everybody no one's it no one can
deny the chickens are hilarious and
heartwarming they are hilarious
can i before read another super chat i
just want to shout ian out because this
was a very packed full house tonight and
he had to uh he and i had a conversation
about who's going to do this show
tonight he very gracefully agreed to let
me do it so he could have a panel of
papers very gracious uh and so he'll be
he'll be back but just wanted to thank
him shane was like come on man there's
so many catholics come on we gotta take
it over man you know there's a lot of
catholics here because like the first
thing we talk about is the principle of
double effect
all right so we got a bunch of super
chats from back during the conversation
about abortion sandy warren says do
ectopic pregnancies and placenta previa
count as abortion no yeah no i i know
that i can't i can only speak to ectopic
pregnancies i know that even webmd and
planned parenthood have said they're not
classified as abortions so really yeah
interesting well it's not an abortion if
it's not in the womb hmm
all right here we go wha what is this
it's like kleinfeldt josh transgenderism
it's the same thing like when talking
about actual genetic and problems that
are going on in the body just a whole
other category exactly but they want
they want to select that one edge case
in order to justify everything else and
the double the double effect principle
applies to the ectopic pressure
effect all right josh karen says elijah
being on the show made me double check
what show i was watching where is sydney
uh she is back in dallas but i'm here
live and i'm traveling so i don't know
yeah we were like dude come on our show
your show's dumb yeah he's like you're
right he's like he's like get the hell
out of dallas and i'm like i don't want
to get shot in deep ellen i want to go
drink a beer in magic well we you know
actually elijah didn't want to come on
the show but we fired up our
transportation device which ricocheted
off the satellite just beamed him here
literally i was like walking to the
stage i showed up and i'm like oh my
gosh it's my favorite lgbt author well
and i
also
i really want to reaffirm that what that
raid did is it it vaporized him and then
duplicated him elsewhere because that's
how transporters work so the original
elijah is no more i already died but
then i had to go into that maze.com
child teaching kids about sex sites
you know what you can teleport me yeah
that's fine i was like kill the rest of
me all right draconian planet with
rikers draconian says i find yeah
draconia says oh star trek reference
always worked for me draconian says i
find it really interesting the new york
subway incident happened the very next
day after biden announced the radical
gun control agenda the government
wouldn't create a crisis to push
legislation right
uh well i actually think it's more more
so just the media wouldn't over cover
certain stories and go nuts with them to
pursue some kind of political agenda you
know when when ukraine happens all of a
sudden every media outlet is like come
on stand with ukraine and i'm like you
know we don't see this for every other
war the us is engaged in every other
conflict you know got people walking
around with saudi arabia or yemen flags
talking about conflict over there
weapons sales you don't see it with
afghanistan or iraq so when the media
latches on and pushes the narrative
that's the question i have not whether
people stage stuff i mean they do but
it's also the media just being like oh
look at that thing
all right joshua sheldon says matt
as to the new skirmish you're starting
with libertarians should there be a
limit to using the law to cover all of
morality should drunken hookup culture
be outlawed
well you have to be more specific about
outlawing drunken hookup culture i mean
i i would be
i would entertain some laws that might
curtail at some but that's kind of
that's kind of a broad question i i
think though look with the legislating
morality but
um what we have to understand is that
every law legislates morality because
every law is based in some sense of what
is good and what is bad because if you
weren't legislating morality as they say
then what you'd be making laws what
arbitrarily you'd be making laws with no
with no idea of what if it's if it's
good or bad maybe that's what's actually
happening yeah but there is now we do
have laws that are legislating morality
wrongly or with or or according to the
wrong moral code but uh at the end of
the day it does come down to whether
it's good or bad so it's kind of like
everything that's illegal
nothing should be illegal unless it's
bad
that doesn't mean that every bad thing
should be illegal there used to be laws
against to hook up culture basically
there used to be this law um
there used to be a crime of seduction
that i think is still on the books in
mississippi perhaps yeah so the crime of
seduction would be if you were um if you
were a young woman who slept with a man
who had promised to marry you and you
slept with him under the pretenses that
he was going to marry you and then he
didn't marry you you could he could be
charged with the crime of seduction oh
wow yeah that's that's crazy rvs being
mad about us fighting against hookup
culture every rv needs hook up so
all right my dad's joking today my dad
joke of the day black tsar says the
failing of the drunk driver to pregnancy
analogy is that it presumes it is by
state design a system exists whereby one
must provide vital aid to another but in
reality the system predates society the
umbilical cord is not a social contract
what comes after is
interesting
all right
billy two cents says just a question
wouldn't a woman getting an abortion be
the equivalent of hiring a hitman in
that case why not punish the woman you
wouldn't just punish the hit man in a
similar situation
what if and just to elaborate uh or to
expand upon this often the the assassins
are government agents undercover to
arrest the woman who wants to kill her
husband or husband and his wife what if
you eventually end up with g-man
abortion doctors and the wind go in and
then he's like pulled out his badge like
i gotcha you're under arrest well even
the law in oklahoma doesn't punish the
woman it punches the doctor right i
think it's just saying hypothetically
under this premise yeah you get into
this question about should you punish
the woman i mean i think it's just like
any other just like with our murder laws
that govern the murder of born people
it's it's it's you look at the at the
circumstances it's not like you have one
penalty in place for murder there's
different degrees of murder and so on so
i think if abortion is characterized
legally as murder which it should be
it's going to be sort of like the the
same sort of thing you know yeah
yeah i would agree with that
there certainly have been uh
places where the woman was criminalized
for
um held criminally liable for abortion
or attempted abortion yeah and there
have also been instances where people
have been charged with uh killing an
unborn child when it wasn't there so for
example a man someone can be charged
with double homicide anything yeah so
like someone can be charged with double
homicide if they kill someone who's
up
pregnant
this guy and he like he killed his wife
and uh her unborn baby and then he was
charged with this black guy oh wow it
was in boston am i getting everything
screwed up i think it was in boston
scott peterson
oh there was peterson too yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah scott peterson yeah here's
i don't know who scott lacy is i have no
idea lacey peterson you mean lacey
peters there you go
no it's all right i'll start throwing
names out just throw it all out there
i just gotta say i mean if if abortion
is illegal then everybody involved
should be criminally liable for it i
absolutely believe that but that doesn't
mean
um
what what is the penalty and all that
then you have to look at the at the
individual circumstances just like you
do with any other murder yeah i was
because i was asked this oh i just want
to clarify i was asked this question on
the last show and my thinking at the
time was basically well um a lot of
these women don't know what they're
doing etc i think they're lied to by the
abortion industry and i still argue that
we should take those things into account
but again if we believe that it's murder
then it becomes a question of what kind
of punishment
and not necessarily a question of
is there punishment at all michael
tierney says tim once they allow
abortions for rape victims false rape
accusations will skyrocket an innocent
man will be in prison
perhaps what do you guys think will
women make up rape stories just to be
able to get an abortion and put kill a
baby and then put a guy in prison i mean
that sounds a bit extreme right well
that is one of the many problems with
the rape exception is that it's just how
do you even enforce it in the first
place so when you you know i think you
shouldn't have the exception because the
baby it's it's wrong to kill the baby
but also
you put that exception in place then
right it is hard to how do you how do
you
differentiate how do you enforce that do
you consider yourself pro-choice libby
you know i continue to be
uh have questions about this issue i
definitely am not in favor of abortion i
don't think anyone should have an
abortion
um i think it's exactly the wrong thing
to do and i don't think anyone should do
it i do have questions about um
you know
situations of rape and incest i do have
questions about that um
yeah so i think i think that the way to
pursue it is to encourage a value system
that values parenthood that values
mothers that values life i bring this up
because we have a good one vincent young
says you can't have the government
decide abortion humanity has to want
life it's the only way to change
consciousness and you might i agree with
that i i think you were not applying to
infanticide though
what what that argument well the
government can't ban abortion people
just have to not want to do it because
they should want life too it's not
saying they should they they they they
shouldn't it's saying to solve the
problem oh okay and i think you brought
up earlier there's a cultural issue i do
think that's right yeah there's actually
um an anti-abortion
advocate in texas um
destiny destiny hernandez do i have her
name right i don't remember exactly but
she her her organization works to
encourage motherhood
right she's not trying to change policy
she's trying to change women's minds
brian prius says if an unborn person's
value is dependent upon the condition of
conception is it wrong to kill the same
person post birth if conceived by rape
if so why the difference a person is
always a person deserving of a chance of
life i completely agree with that i was
always confused by a conservative
argument that there's an exception for
rape and incest in terms of killing the
baby right now you know the the argument
or the discussion i say we we had was
making a person carry the baby that they
didn't choose to but i think we you know
there's that uh
the ultimate conclusion was
uh a woman won't die from having the
baby but the baby will die from the
abortion and that's why i was making the
point about with with born children we
have no problem saying to the parent no
matter how the child was conceived but
you have a responsibility to that child
and
so i think i don't see why we can't
apply the same principle all right so we
we got a bunch of these ones and there
were some directed at you uh kyle bruvs
uh brus veen says tim poole quote can't
kill anyone on death row in case they
are not guilty also tim cool in cases of
rape kill the innocent child slash
victim tim you are almost there no i've
repeatedly said i think abortion is
wrong i think there's a challenge in
answering ethical questions around what
the government has the right to enforce
in certain circumstances as pertains to
individuals life liberty and pursuit of
happiness while fully acknowledging
every time that life begins at
conception i just think that there's
ethical challenges but but i think if
there's any issue with no middle ground
it is absolutely abortion it is it is a
a spire and you're on one side or the
other there's no there's no teetering in
the middle of that one
i don't know if you wanted to
yeah i mean i'm thoroughly opposed to
abortion
i'm thoroughly opposed to capital
punishment as well i don't think that
government should be
um
killing prisoners either i think the
issue is the left has turned what was
supposed to amount to safe legal and
rare as a begrudging compromise they
turned it into you get an abortion
you know that's sort of the real issue
for me um it was so interesting like i i
was raised catholic by my dad's second
wife uh
and i went to catholic school and we saw
uh videos of abortion when i was in
eighth grade um and i was i've been
entirely opposed to abortion ever since
then and my mom thought it was
horrifying when i eventually moved in
with her that i was so opposed to
abortion
um and so i've had decades of debate
with my mom on this issue
i i gotta give a shout out to the 800
people who said adoption in the super
chats yes definitely a lot of people
have mentioned adoption i agree i
definitely do my yeah my family wouldn't
exist without adoption uh yeah i i
disagree with the idea of abortion as
contraception i think it used to be in
this country that was the case
but now the left mother and left is just
like why not
the other issue too that we have is that
there's this idea that you shouldn't be
ashamed of having an abortion that you
shouldn't feel bad about it and that
also i think is an issue that you're
supposed to be like yay i had an
abortion you know i saw a cake today and
it was like uh it's an abortion instead
of it's a boy um
it was like you know some
that's also a massive thing and that's a
huge issue for me as well that like this
is something that you know people
hollywood celebrities get up and accept
awards saying i couldn't have done this
if i didn't kill my baby it's like
that's a horrifying horrifying it is
horrifying
that's like that's that's massive
overcompensation on their part you know
that's that's that's them trying to
convince themselves by convincing the
rest of us that they're happy with it
they're not upset about it and i think
it's true because i i i'm pretty sure we
were talking about this on the show a
few months ago that people who have kids
develop a harder drive
so it's like i don't understand why you
know terminating your children makes you
better in fact most stories i know are
people who are like
when they had kids they became more
driven and and like i have it makes it
so much easier to prioritize what you
want to do and what you don't want to do
like after my son was born and i wanted
to spend time i wanted to like properly
mother my child it was so much easier
when like some random project came up to
just be like nope not doing that one you
know just don't care i'm gonna do i'm
gonna hang out with my kid instead
all right we got a ton of super chats on
this one debate but i don't want to just
uh take the whole super chat up by
people guys yeah but really really you
know great points i appreciate it um and
i'll shout out to bret tesdale and
everybody else who keeps saying yo yo
guys mention adoption uh he says i'm
adopt an adopted child an adoptive
parent and it's infuriating the adoption
option is often disregarded no i
completely agree with adoption and
there's a huge wait list parents want to
adopt kids man for for infant adoption
in particular there's a yeah how about
adopt older children yeah you know like
i think adopting older children is a is
a really strong good move
all right sanity clause says the ban for
talking about veteran status was
specifically created to get rid of navy
of a navy seal who was outing people who
lied about serving slash type of service
like being a seal ranger income etc left
slanted policy not meant to protect real
vets
interesting i mean i remember seeing
that and i was like really veterans you
can't disparage veterans i mean you
should you shouldn't
you know you disparage people for being
bad people i suppose but yeah
all right john castle says tim and co
talking of a movie the daily wire could
make look up the battle of castle
itter i for one think it'd make a great
movie
interesting is there a movie is there a
beowulf movie yes
really is it good i haven't seen it
i don't know do you like the story of
beowulf yeah well maybe you'll like it
maybe but you know as they often make
movies they were they're not always they
they don't always make great movies
no not to give says matt and libby hit
an important point kids are learning
that natural changes are a disease
that's that's creepy to me it was just
like you know you're gonna go through
puberty something's gonna happen welcome
to life and now we're like but we can
stop it with technology
and what is that gonna do to people you
know i reinforced to my son who's
probably gonna be a big tall guy
i did tell him i'm like you're gonna
grow up to be a really big tall guy and
that's great that's a great thing to be
you gotta show them chicken city oh oh
he's seen chickens because you see the
rooster
you know here's the fascinating thing
and you know i'll take every opportunity
to mention chicken city when we got the
chickens we were told they were all hens
and they all looked the same and then
one day we're like that one's starting
to look a little different what's going
on chicken puberty now roberto is
puberty he's twice as tall as the other
ones
they behave differently no one these
chickens didn't have parents they were
hatched put in a box orphaned chickens
but but they they develop these
characteristics because you know sexual
dimorphism is a thing
and you can you can you can see that
plus we have we have the babies hatching
a very educational show good for kids so
you adopted all these chickens chicken
run by the way side note was an
incredible oh yeah and it was actually
the first movie there was chicken run
too as well i didn't see it now we have
chicken run three chicken city which is
uh the next the next installment i just
said i
have this experience so often as a
parent i tried to cause that's actually
a kids movie that i can watch and endure
and i tried to show it to my to my kids
and they just they hated it oh no oh my
gosh you know it's sad though because
that's that's another form of animation
that's just been lost because
everything's cg now that claymation and
that film is so masterfully animated
very comical too yeah all right fireball
we watch listen grommet at my house and
we like it firebelly says that's better
taste than my kids
matt have you considered broadening your
academic pursuits into fat studies oh
hey
this is a smart move yeah yeah well i
know stephen crowder already had that
covered yeah yeah right that's right he
did a good job on that yeah i'm kind of
stuck you know i'm branching out slowly
but right now i'm kind of settled as a
woman's study scholar i saw i saw meme
and it was like matt walsh comma who
doesn't know what a woman is comma i
thought it was a funny insult because
i'm like yo it's you guys who can't
answer the question yeah like
you defined it every opportunity you had
so their insult is you can't when
it's it's them that's the joke yeah so
it's not like like socrates who doesn't
know what impiety was like the point is
you ask the question because you know
the answer but you know they don't right
that's all they can do yeah you know but
uh i mean it's fascinating i wonder what
parents i'm really curious to see what
happens since this november i don't
think just voting republican solves
anything i think voting in the primaries
and knowing who you're voting for can
help solve some things but i'm wondering
how many parents are going to be like
yeah i'm not going to vote for those
people because they can't define what a
woman is
i wonder how many suburban housewives
are going to be like i think i know what
a woman is and when they try to when
they try to flip it around on us
it's like well you could i mean i have a
i haven't mentioned it i have a movie
coming out called what is one go towards
and um you could easily embarrass me in
particular but a lot of us
just by
giving a definition just give a
definition of the word
i've got like a book and a movie coming
out you could you could totally negate
that and make it really embarrassing by
just defining give me give me the
definition
would you accept um the oxford
dictionary
yeah but that's that's the that's the
definition they don't want to give like
adult human female is the definition but
if you don't want to go with that
definition then what is it and they
can't do that can i it's go ahead i just
want to ask you uh is there anything
even close to a coherent definition you
got from anyone
absolutely not wow that's that you know
absolutely not that's what it
is no matt that is weird because what i
way i thought you were done no no no no
also saw was was a total gaslight
recently was
people keep saying especially
conservatives biological males and
biological females okay as if there is
no but but as if there is like when
you're in biology you never said well
this is a biological there's a reason
but there's a reason that this is said
well i know why people say it people say
it because otherwise you're going to get
banned on social media i mean and you're
going to get yourself and you're going
to come up against canadians i'm just
saying we've had to add
an american a
that's better not to say biological
email because it does seem to insinuate
or imply rather than other there's
another type
when i say i agree as well when i when i
say it i say it more and i'm trying not
to say anymore but for me was always
like a point of emphasis it's like
saying i used to say it too it's like
it's like saying i'm standing on solid
grounds like well of course the ground
is solid it's just emphasizing that the
ground is solid
right biological male just emphasizes
the bible what if you said something
like leah thomas is the first male to
win the women's ncaa swim you know you
get banned on twitter and you know and
you're i tweeted yeah did you get banned
no i didn't no scientific work right
well maybe it's gonna start switching
back maybe we're gonna start being able
to say the truth online again now that
elon musk has those shares
who knows there's several issues one is
elitism how powerful are you on their
platform and they try to avoid big
splash bans and suspensions so i've got
a million twitter followers oh yeah i
definitely don't right exactly so
there's there's a privilege in that
because twitter's like this would be bad
for the platform and it would also
create a big wave of news which we don't
want so we'll you know we'll give passes
to certain people but also i look at
their rules very carefully and i know
what i tweet doesn't break the rules and
the left flips out they're like tim paul
is transphobic i'm not gonna disparage
nobody i i you don't you agree that true
thomas is bilaterally male i'm not
disparaging leah thomas in fact i
actually argued uh uh that the women
weren't speaking up and that if the
rules were set and no parent complained
and no swimmer complained why should i
be mad about something they're not
complaining about i did find it
incredibly frustrating that no one uh
that so few people were willing to put
their face and name to their complaints
you had parents speaking anonymously
swimmers speaking anonymously it was
infuriating we just talked to jonathan
isaac he's the nba player who refused to
kneel for black lives matter during the
the the anthem and they got mad at him
they're like hey everyone's doing this
and he's like it's not what i believe
and he's like i'm not mad at you for
kneeling i just this is what i believe
and i was like you know it was so
refreshing to hear this story we
interviewed him for us for a special
we're doing and i was just like that's
amazing dude and it's like this is what
you feel is what you believe like i
don't care if colin kaepernick wants to
kneel or whatever but he brought
politics into the game he brought
politics into the game and i can
understand people being like we don't
want it here now that they've made
everything about politics as a guy who's
saying like i don't want to kneel and
i'm like you shouldn't have to
if you want to politicize the game make
up politics the one guy who just stands
like a nor like they normally do is now
being
told he's making it political i'm like
he's the guy who's not making it
political everyone else is
all right let's just do uh we'll do a
couple more super chats here
box fed tv says matt i live in hollywood
my writer friends have scripts how can
they get them to you guys they want out
of hollywood
the daily wire yeah i don't know if i'm
illegally allowed to answer that well
just get in touch with uh go to
dailywire.com and
go through that i don't know people
people should understand um there are
challenges to
sending unsolicited materials anywhere
have you ever watched you guys ever see
you ever see airheads
he uh brendan fraser's character sneaks
into the record label and he's like
check out my cd and he's like that is
not solicited i cannot look at it right
because it what happens is
someone sends an email an employee looks
at it now the company can never go
anywhere near anything related to that
content because they'll get accused of
stealing it so they're just like no no
don't send it to me i guess is the
answer go to dailywire.com and maybe
make your own movie like get some
funding make your own stuff yeah make
more content yeah
you don't need permission like just just
get your truck and move and make your
movie somewhere
g uh goff says so fun to see matt talk
about aliens it is a happy day for matt
even though it doesn't show yes
yeah i was really glad that we were able
to get into that that's that's nice do
you i'm i'm totally outnumbered at the
daily wire by the way without this
conversation on the backstage shows and
i'm just like
it's me against the world there on the
alien topic
they just they don't believe it or left
the wrong company because i feel like
i'm the one outnumbered where i'm like
not big into extraterrestrial everyone's
like i just sit there and i'm like i'm
not going to try to make a case because
i'm sitting with like five p it's always
i'm sitting around five people that are
like big on the extraterrestrial so i'm
just like whatever
yeah it is and it's tough too because
like i've having this debate and then
like ben shapiro's on the other side and
i gotta debate him about he's like hit
that's actually alien's ridiculous okay
he's got all the facts about you know
the universe and stuff and it's like
yep all right everybody i i doubt that
he has all the facts about the universe
he literally has all the facts oh my god
michael knowles burns you on a ukulele
all right if you have not already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have that special extra
spicy members only segment coming up at
11 p.m eastern so it'll be up soon and
as a member you'll support all of our
journalists and help keep all of this uh
this rolling so we really do appreciate
it you can follow the show at tim cast
irl you can follow me at tim cast
basically everywhere matt do you want to
shout anything out
yes uh what is a woman.com i have my
documentary coming out in in may i can't
say a lot about it but we'll have uh be
revealing very soon some more it'll be
a lot of people can be very angry when
they see it that's all all right
elijah what's up uh a little more quiet
today a little more pensive let's listen
to the wise people speak as always and
if you want to hear a podcast that it's
not the wisest person in the world but
it's a hell of a lot of fun check out
slightly offensive on youtube apple
podcasts anywhere you can find them and
also i was thinking with chicken city
i was like dude is there some sort of a
goal like if we reach a certain amount
of donation number we get to see a
chicken raise we get to see who's the
real dominant or is there any type of
goals that we're reaching there is i
want to give so so chicken party is the
first for every hundred dollars that's
that's donated through super chats or
you know given to feed the chickens a
chicken party happens the next thing
we're thinking is after 10 chicken
parties in one day ian goes out and
plays music for the chickens
something like that but that requires to
come out
you know
before 7pm or something so you know give
him some crystals or something yeah yeah
hell yeah okay it's my turn yeah it's
your turn
uh i'm libby emmons and uh you could
help me get to a million followers on
twitter at libby emmons and i'm at
thepostmillennial.com every day if you
want to help us out we're
thepostmillennial.com
contribute also i'm going to be at the
better discourse event in fort worth
not this coming weekend because that's
easter but the following weekend if you
want to come check that out it's
betterdiscourseevent.com
i'm seamus coughlin we just uploaded a
cartoon on freedom tunes today i
honestly think it's one of the funniest
videos we've done in a while i really
want you guys to go check that out i
think you'll love it just go to freedom
tunes check it out it's called biden's
fallen and he can't get up
and
i'll uh i'll turn it over to you guys
all right yeah i'm also here in the
corner i finally figured out how to
press my buttons once again with this
new camera setup you guys may follow me
on twitter at sourpatchlids also
mines.com and sourpatchlids.me
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you